Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at PathwaysAlliance.ca
加拿大的油砂开采产生了大量的碳排放。因此，六家最大的公司携手合作，在迈向净零排放的道路上取得了长足进步。通过投资技术与创新，他们已经将每个原油桶的平均排放量削减了 22%。他们与政府合作，创造并保护就业岗位，并正在开发世界上最大的碳捕集与封存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在推进中，并且我们在多个方向上都取得了进展。请访问 PathwaysAlliance.ca 了解我们的计划。
In late January 2009, South Eastern Australia was impacted by a blistering heat wave considered to be one of the most, if not the most, extreme in the region's history. It caused prolonged record-breaking temperatures that reached nearly 50 degrees Celsius in some locations. In the state of Victoria, this extreme heat caused power outages that resulted in the termination of public transport services and traffic light failures. Large public venues in the city of Melbourne were evacuated and the annual Australian Open Tennis Tournament was also impacted, with several outdoor matches cancelled. American tennis champion Serena Williams remarked that it was so hot on court
在 2009 年 1 月下旬，澳大利亚东南部受到了一场酷热热浪的袭击，这场热浪被认为是该地区历史上最极端的热浪之一，甚至可以说是最极端的一次。它导致气温持续打破纪录，某些地方的温度接近 50 摄氏度。在维多利亚州，这种极端高温导致了电力中断，进而导致公共交通服务暂停以及红绿灯故障。墨尔本市的大型公共场馆被疏散，年度澳大利亚网球公开赛也受到了影响，几场户外比赛被取消。美国网球名将塞雷娜·威廉姆斯（Serena Williams）表示，球场上的温度实在太高了
that she felt she was having an out-of-body experience. People were stranded inside lifts that had ceased operating. Wooden power poles were witnessed self-igniting and bushfires blazed across the state. Thousands of citizens required medical treatment, resulting in a 70% increase in emergency calls to ambulance Victoria, while the death rate increased by 45%. By the following month of February, the heat wave had cost the Victorian economy an estimated $100 million. On Friday, February 6, State Premier John Brumby cautioned the Victorians about the extreme weather conditions forecast for the next day, announcing that Saturday, February 7, 2009 would be the worst day in the history of the state.
以至于她觉得自己有了灵魂出窍的体验。人们被困在停止运行的电梯里。人们亲眼目睹了木制电线杆自燃，丛林大火在整个州肆虐。成千上万的市民需要医疗救助，导致维多利亚救护车的紧急呼叫量增加了 70%，而死亡率则上升了 45%。到了接下来的 2 月份，这场热浪给维多利亚州经济造成了估计 1 亿美元的损失。2 月 6 日星期五，州长约翰·布伦比（John Brumby）就次日预报的极端天气条件向维多利亚州人民发出警告，宣布 2009 年 2 月 7 日星期六将是该州历史上最糟糕的一天。
Temperatures were once again set to soar above the mid-40s and a gale-force wind was predicted. A decade-long drought had left much of the Australian landscape incredibly dry and Victoria alone had missed the equivalent of two years worth of average rainfall. Premier Brumby encouraged people to cancel plans, avoid travelling and stay at home. Warning, it's just as bad a day as you can imagine and on top of that, the state is just tinder dry. People need to exercise real common sense tomorrow. Victoria had a long, disastrous history of wildfires and the weather conditions were predicted to be worse for those that preceded the devastating Ash Wednesday and Black Friday bushfires in 1983 and 1939, respectively.
气温预计将再次飙升至 40 度以上，并且预计会有烈风。长达十年的干旱使澳大利亚的大片土地异常干燥，仅维多利亚州就错过了相当于两年总量的平均降雨量。布伦比州长鼓励人们取消计划，避免出行并呆在家里。他警告说：“这将是你所能想象到的最糟糕的一天，最重要的是，这个州干得就像引火物一样。明天人们需要真正展现出常识。”维多利亚州有着漫长而灾难性的野火历史，据预测，当天的天气状况将比 1983 年和 1939 年分别引发毁灭性“灰烬星期三”和“黑色星期五”丛林大火的天气还要糟糕。
The MacArthur Forest Fire Danger Index, which combined climate data such as temperature, wind speed and humidity, anticipated a result for February 7, 2009 that exceeded the algorithm's highest category of extreme. Thus, a new category was created titled Catastrophic. A total fire ban was declared and hundreds of firefighting personnel were deployed statewide. As anticipated, the weather on February 7 was sweltering with many new all-time maximums reached. Melbourne recorded its hottest ever temperature at 46.6 degrees Celsius. Throughout Victoria, bushfires ignited, fanned by high winds that blanketed the state in thick smoke. As their intensity grew, Australia's national broadcaster, the ABC, abandoned its scheduled programming to report solely on the hazardous situation.
麦克阿瑟森林火灾危险指数结合了温度、风速和湿度等气候数据，预计 2009 年 2 月 7 日的结果将超过算法中最高的“极端”类别。因此，一个名为“灾难性”的新类别被创建了。全州宣布实施全面禁火令，数百名消防人员部署到了全州各地。正如预期那样，2 月 7 日的天气酷热难耐，许多历史最高气温被刷新。墨尔本录得了 46.6 摄氏度的历史最高气温。在整个维多利亚州，丛林大火纷纷燃起，在大风的助长下，滚滚浓烟笼罩了整个州。随着火势的加剧，澳大利亚国家广播公司（ABC）取消了原定的节目编排，转而专门报道这一危险的情况。
Meanwhile, residents in rural and regional fire prone areas debated whether they should stay and defend their homes or evacuate and risk losing everything. Located in the rural region of Gippsland in Victoria's East is the La Trobe Valley. An inland district with three major urban areas, Maui, Morwell and Tarragan, and six smaller townships, including Churchill. Formerly known as Hazelwood, Churchill was purpose-built to accommodate workers involved in the construction and maintenance of the Hazelwood Power Station. In 1965, the town was renamed in posthumous honour of former British Prime Minister Sir Winston Churchill and grew into a commuter suburb for those working in neighbouring areas. Located 160 kilometres southeast of Melbourne, Churchill fetches a commercial centre for its several thousand locals, with wide parklands separating residential areas from industrial estates. Dense tree plantations, a national park and eight ridges of farmland frame the township, which is home to the scenic Lake Highland and a golden tower known locally as the Big Cigar after Winston Churchill's trademark smoking habit. At 1.32pm on Saturday, February 7, 2009, 000 emergency services received a call regarding a wildfire just outside Churchill.
与此同时，位于农村和易发火灾地区的居民们正在争论，他们是该留下来保卫家园，还是撤离并冒着失去一切的风险。吉普斯兰（Gippsland）农村地区位于维多利亚州东部，是拉特罗布山谷（La Trobe Valley）所在的地方。这是一个内陆地区，拥有莫威、莫威尔和塔拉甘这三个主要市区，以及包括丘吉尔（Churchill）在内的六个较小的城镇。丘吉尔原名为黑兹尔伍德（Hazelwood），是为安置参与黑兹尔伍德发电厂建设和维护的工人而专门修建的。1965 年，为了死后纪念前英国首相温斯顿·丘吉尔爵士，该镇更名为丘吉尔，并发展成为周边地区工人的通勤卫星城。丘吉尔镇位于墨尔本东南 160 公里处，为其几千名当地居民提供了一个商业中心，宽阔的公园将住宅区与工业区隔开。茂密的树木种植园、一个国家公园和八道农田构成了这个城镇的轮廓，这里拥有风景秀丽的高地湖（Lake Highland），以及一座因温斯顿·丘吉尔标志性的吸烟习惯而被当地人称为“大雪茄”（Big Cigar）金色高塔。2009 年 2 月 7 日星期六下午 1 点 32 分，000 紧急服务中心接到了一通关于丘吉尔镇郊外发生野火的电话。
The blaze was four kilometres southeast of town, near the intersection of Glen Donald Road and Jelliff's Outlet, two unsealed stretches of winding roadway that cut through the rural outskirts. It had emerged from the bottom of a natural basin, the Bennett's Creek catchment, which consisted of blue gum, eucalypt and pine plantations, surrounded by hazardous surface fuels such as shrubs, wire grass and blackberry bushes. Three minutes after the call, a pilot flying a firefighting aircraft ten kilometres from Churchill sighted a column of dark smoke hundreds of feet high rising from the fire's location. Within ten minutes, the flames had travelled roughly one kilometre and were in the vicinity of forests managed by timber company, Hancock Victorian Plantations. The plantations' surveillance planes, which were overseeing the entirety of the Latrobe Valley that day, were diverted to Churchill to carry out reconnaissance work. Despite being in its early stages, the fire's behaviour was noted as extreme. By the time first responders arrived, the blaze had spread rapidly and was burning on both sides of Jelliff's Outlet. Spotfires began igniting around it, straining resources and impacting efforts to tackle the central inferno directly.
大火位于镇东南四公里处，靠近格伦唐纳德路（Glen Donald Road）和杰利夫出口（Jelliff's Outlet）的交叉口，这两条穿过农村郊区的未铺砌蜿蜒道路。火势起源于一个自然盆地的底部——班尼特溪（Bennett's Creek）流域，这里由蓝桉、按树和松树种植园组成，周围环绕着灌木、铁丝草和黑莓灌木丛等危险的地表可燃物。在接到电话三分钟后，一名驾驶消防飞机在距离丘吉尔十公里处飞行的飞行员发现了火灾地点升起了一根数百英尺高的浓黑烟柱。在十分钟内，火焰已经蔓延了大约一公里，并到达了由木材公司汉考克维多利亚种植园（Hancock Victorian Plantations）管理的森林附近。种植园的侦察机当天一直在巡视整个拉特罗布山谷，它们被调往丘吉尔执行侦察任务。尽管火灾尚处于初期阶段，但其火势行为已被注意到属于极端情况。当第一批应急人员赶到时，大火已经迅速蔓延，并在杰利夫出口的两侧燃烧。零星飞火开始在其周围点燃，这使得救援资源吃紧，并影响了直接扑灭中心烈火的努力。
Requests were made for more tankers and air support, however, the intense heat was causing water to evaporate before it even hit the ground. The focus then shifted to warning surrounding communities of the urgent threat. Roadblocks were established around the fire as emergency services personnel visited nearby residences to raise the alarm. By 2pm, the fire had been raging for almost half an hour and remained out of control, despite the arrival of additional firefighting crews. It continued to move in a south-easterly direction through the broad valley of Bennett's Creek. Aircrew observed the fire cresting the ridge along Jeralang North Road and by the 50-minute mark it had travelled about 7km. More spotfires were reported and by 3pm, the blaze had burned through a pine plantation and damaged a communications tower. Efforts to protect assets continued as emergency relief centres were established in nearby townships.
有关部门请求调派更多的水罐车和空中支援，然而，强烈的热火导致水在击中地面之前就已经蒸发了。工作重点随即转为向周边社区发出紧急威胁警告。火灾周围设立了路障，应急服务人员走访了附近的居民区以拉响警报。到下午 2 点时，大火已经肆虐了近半个小时，尽管增援的消防队伍陆续赶到，但火势仍然失控。它继续沿着班尼特溪宽阔的山谷向东南方向移动。机组人员观察到大火越过了杰拉朗北路（Jeralang North Road）沿线的山脊，到 50 分钟标记时，它已经蔓延了大约 7 公里。更多飞火被报道，到下午 3 点，大火已经烧穿了一个松树种植园，并损毁了一座通信塔。随着在附近城镇建立紧急救援中心，保护资产的努力仍在继续。
At 3.20pm, the fire had destroyed its first homestead at the intersection of Thompson and Jeralang North Roads. By 5.15pm, it was approaching the slopes of Mount Tassie, 10km due southeast of Churchill and spotting to the mountain's east side. As emergency crews tackled the surrounding spotfires, the apex of the inferno raged onwards. Earlier that day, Australia's Bureau of Meteorology had predicted a severe wind change that would hit Gippsland between 6 and 8pm. Shortly before 4 o'clock, their prediction was amended to the window of 5.30pm and 7pm. The planning officer responsible for the Churchill fire, unaware of the amendment, told the incident management team to expect it at the midpoint of 7pm. When the change arrived an hour earlier than anticipated, it sent 70km an hour gusts through the region that suddenly shifted the fire in a northeasterly direction. The winds posed a significant threat to aircrafts and forced them to land as a 15km long uncontrolled flank of fire developed that ran from the origin point near Churchill through to the east side of Mount Tassie.
下午 3 点 20 分，大火烧毁了它在汤普森路（Thompson）和杰拉朗北路交叉口的第一处宅基地。到下午 5 点 15 分，它正在接近位于丘吉尔正东南 10 公里的塔西山（Mount Tassie）山坡，并在该山东侧出现飞火。正当应急队伍扑救周边飞火时，烈火的顶峰继续肆虐。当天早些时候，澳大利亚气象局曾预测，一场强烈的风向转变将在下午 6 点至 8 点之间袭击吉普斯兰。但在近 4 点时，他们的预测被修正到了下午 5 点 30 分至 7 点之间。负责丘吉尔火灾的规划官并不知道这一修正，他告诉事件管理团队预计风向转变将发生在中间时间即下午 7 点。当风向转变比预期提前一小时到来时，它在当地引发了每小时 70 公里的阵风，突然将火势转为向东北方向蔓延。大风对飞机构成了重大威胁，迫使它们降落，与此同时，一条长达 15 公里的失控火线从丘吉尔附近的起火点一直延伸到塔西山的东侧。
As it progressed forward, burning debris rained down and ignited the surrounding vegetation almost instantly. It was accompanied by an ear-splitting rush of white noise described by witnesses as the sound of immense pressure, like that of a jet engine. Following this hurricane-like wind change, the fire was at its most dangerous, threatening multiple townships as well as the one-ron state forest. Residents working fervently to defend their homes were now blinded by an all-encompassing blackness composed of smoke and dash. All of a sudden, the inbound firestorm appeared through the dark like a sunrise. Churchill resident Greg Weir stated, I knew the firefront was coming, you could hear it, you could smell it, you could feel the heat coming up out of the valley. The flames were right there and were the height of the trees and that again, 300ft high plus.
随着火势向前推进，燃烧的碎片如雨般落下，几乎瞬间点燃了周围的植被。伴随着这一过程的是刺耳的白噪音呼啸声，目击者将其描述为巨大压力的声音，就像喷气发动机一样。在这场飓风般的风向转变之后，火灾达到了最危险的时刻，威胁着多个城镇以及单龙国有森林。奋力保卫家园的居民们现在被由烟雾和灰烬组成的无孔不入的黑暗弄得睁不开眼。突然之间，逼近的火风暴像日出一样穿透黑暗出现。丘吉尔居民格雷格·韦尔（Greg Weir）表示：“我知道火锋正在逼近，你能听到它，你能闻到它，你能感觉到热浪从山谷里涌上来。火焰就在那里，有树木那么高，而且再次强调，高度超过了 300 英尺。”
There were big, swirling vortexes, just big, swirling masses of flames that would burst and explode out of the treetops. Shortly after 6pm, three water tankers belonging to volunteer fire service, the Country Fire Authority, were involved in a series of burnovers, wherein their crews were forced to take shelter where possible as the fire entrapped them. The burnover hit with, quote, great ferocity. Firefighter Graham Chesterton recalled, I could see embers start to fall, it was like they were coming from everywhere, it became very smoky and everything started to burn rapidly. There were spotfires on the ground all around me and the trees started burning. At that stage, I guessed I had about 10 to 15 seconds until I would have to make a move. Within those seconds, the conditions deteriorated so rapidly that I realised it wasn't safe to leave the truck.
那里有巨大的、旋转的涡流，只是一团团巨大的、旋转的火焰，从树冠中爆裂并喷涌而出。下午 6 点刚过，志愿消防服务机构“乡村消防局”（Country Fire Authority）的三辆水罐车卷入了一系列“超越火线”（burnovers）事件中，当时火势将他们困住，他们的队员被迫在可能的地方寻找庇护。超越火线以“巨大的凶猛势头”袭来。消防员格雷厄姆·切斯特顿（Graham Chesterton）回忆说：“我可以看到余烬开始落下，就像它们从四面八方飞来一样，周围变得烟雾弥漫，一切都开始迅速燃烧。我周围的地面上到处都是飞火，树木也开始燃烧。当时，我估计我大约有 10 到 15 秒的时间来采取行动。”就在这几秒钟内，情况恶化得如此之快，以至于我意识到离开卡车并不安全。
At that time, I did not know where all my crew members were. I made the decision to make a Mayday call. I said something along the lines of, we are completely surrounded by fire. The burnover lasted an estimated 10 minutes. Firefighting crews elsewhere listened as their colleagues frantically broadcast Mayday calls over radio, but were unable to approach the scene due to the level of danger. All they could do was respond, there is nothing we can do for you. Incredibly, none of the firefighters caught in the burnover lost their lives. The fire finally slowed at 8pm and by the following day of Sunday, February 8, it was mostly brought to a halt, although burning continued in heavily fuelled areas.
当时，我不知道我所有的队员在哪里。我决定发出求救信号。我说了一些类似“我们完全被大火包围了”的话。这场超越火线持续了大约 10 分钟。其他地方的消防队员听到他们的同事在无线机里疯狂地广播求救信号，但由于危险程度太高，他们无法接近现场。他们唯一能做的就是回应：“我们对你们无可奈何。”令人难以置信的是，被困在超越火线中的消防员没有一人丧生。大火最终在晚上 8 点放慢了速度，到第二天 2 月 8 日星期日，火势基本得到了控制，尽管燃料充足的地区仍在继续燃烧。
The Churchill fire, named after its point of origin, was not officially listed as under control until 11 days later on February 19. More than 600 firefighting personnel battled the blaze, supported by 105 vehicles and appliances. In total, it had burnt more than 25,861 hectares and destroyed 145 homes. Elsewhere, 400 separate bushfires had devastated the Victorian landscape, with the most destructive and deadly being the King Lake and Marysville fires in the states northeast. Collectively, the fires had released 80,000 kilowatts of heat, the equivalent of 500 atomic bombs. 173 people had perished and 414 were left injured. More than 2,000 homes and 10,000 kilometres of fence line had been raised and an estimated 1 million animals were killed.
以其起源地命名的丘吉尔大火，直到 11 天后的 2 月 19 日才被官方列为受控状态。600 多名消防人员与大火搏斗，得到了 105 辆车辆和装备的支持。总共烧毁了 25,861 多公顷土地，摧毁了 145 栋房屋。在其他地方，400 起独立的丛林大火摧毁了维多利亚州的景观，其中破坏性最大、最致命的是该州东北部的金湖（King Lake）和玛丽斯维尔（Marysville）大火。这些大火总共释放了 80,000 千瓦的热量，相当于 500 枚原子弹。173 人丧生，414 人受伤。2000 多栋房屋和 10,000 公里长的栅栏线被夷为平地，估计有 100 万只动物死亡。
February 7, 2009, became the deadliest bushfire catastrophe in Victoria's history and was henceforth referred to as Black Saturday. 58-year-old Alfred Frandow and his wife Elaine lived on Old Calagney Road in Calagney with their youngest son, Mark, who was disabled and in their care. The couple had made no plans for what they would do if a bushfire ever threatened their livelihoods, as the possibility never really crossed their minds. On February 7, 2009, a neighbour alerted the Frandows to smoke rising in the direction of Churchill. The fire was nearly 15 kilometres away and to the couple was certain it would not reach their property. As a precaution, they collected a pump, polypiping and a spray nozzle and connected them to the dam near their house. As the fire drew near, Elaine took their son Mark to her parents' house for safety. Alfred remained behind and was soon joined by his eldest son, 27-year-old Scott, who had arrived to help defend his parents' property.
2009 年 2 月 7 日成了维多利亚州历史上最致命的丛林大火灾难，此后被称为“黑色星期六”（Black Saturday）。58 岁的阿尔弗雷德·弗兰多（Alfred Frendow）和他的妻子伊莱恩（Elaine）住在卡拉尼（Calagney）的旧卡拉尼路（Old Calagney Road），与他们的小儿子马克（Mark）一起生活，马克患有残疾，由他们照顾。这对夫妇没有为丛林大火威胁到生计时的应对计划，因为这种可能性从未真正掠过他们的脑海。2009 年 2 月 7 日，一位邻居向弗兰多夫妇发出警报，称丘吉尔方向有烟雾升起。大火距离将近 15 公里，这对夫妇确信火势不会蔓延到他们的房产。作为预防措施，他们收集了一个水泵、塑料管和一个喷嘴，并将它们连接到家附近的水库。随着大火逼近，伊莱恩带着他们的儿子马克去她父母家以确保安全。阿尔弗雷德留了下来，不久他的大儿子、27 岁的斯科特（Scott）也加入进来，赶来帮忙保卫父母的房产。
At 5.59pm, Scott sent his partner a text informing her that although they didn't know exactly how close the fire was, it was very close and they were in trouble. He then phoned his mother to tell her that the hay shed at the bottom of the paddock was on fire and requested she call the fire brigade. Less than half an hour later, Scott phoned a friend who later recalled. He sounded terrified and in a raised voice he said, Get some fucking fire trucks here, before the call dropped out. At 6.30pm, a couple evacuating the area drove past Alfred Frendow's vehicle, which was located about one and a half kilometres from his property and burning on the opposite side of the road. Alfred's body was later found in his car. 60 metres away, resting in burnt bushland off the road, was Scott Frendow's vehicle. His remains were recovered 14 metres from his car.
下午 5 点 59 分，斯科特给他的伴侣发了一条短信，告诉她虽然他们不知道火势具体有多近，但它非常近，而且他们陷入了麻烦。然后他打电话给他母亲，告诉她围场底部的干草棚着火了，并请求她打电话叫消防队。不到半小时后，斯科特给一位朋友打电话，后者回忆说：“他听起来吓坏了，用提高的声音说：‘快弄几辆他妈的消防车来这里’，然后电话就挂断了。”下午 6 点 30 分，一对从该地区撤离的夫妇开车驶过阿尔弗雷德·弗兰多的车辆，该车位于距离他房产约一公里半的地方，正在马路对面燃烧。阿尔弗雷德的尸体后来在他的车里被发现。在 60 米外、路旁烧毁的灌木林中，停着斯科特·弗兰多的车辆。他的遗体在距离他的车 14 米的地方被寻获。
It appeared the father and son had made a last minute decision to evacuate in separate vehicles before Scott had attempted to flee on foot. When Elaine Frendow returned home a week after the fires, she broke down upon discovering her house was still standing. Her husband and son had succeeded in defending the property. For 13 years, Bill and Shirley Gibson had lived in their single story red cedar home on Glendonald Road in Hazelwood South. Built in the 1970s, the house sat on a large sloping bush block surrounded by woodland. The couple kept their property in neat condition, ensuring the lawn was trimmed and the guttering was clear. Shortly before 2pm on February 7, 2009, after the Churchill fire arose within two kilometres of their home, Bill and Shirley elected to leave the property. As they packed their car, one of their son's 49-year-old Colin drove up to the house.
看来这对父子在斯科特试图徒步逃生之前，做出了分别乘坐不同车辆撤离的最后一刻决定。当伊莱恩·弗兰多在火灾发生一周后回到家中时，她发现自己的房子依然完好无损，顿时崩溃大哭。她的丈夫和儿子成功保卫了这处房产。13 年来，比尔（Bill）和雪莉·吉布森（Shirley Gibson）一直住在他们位于黑兹尔伍德南（Hazelwood South）格伦多纳尔德路（Glendonald Road）的单层红雪松住宅里。建于 20世纪 70 年代的房子坐落在一个被林地环绕的大型倾斜灌木街区上。这对夫妇把他们的房产保持得整洁有序，确保草坪修剪整齐，排水沟畅通无阻。2009 年 2 月 7 日下午 2 点前不久，在丘吉尔大火逼近他们家两公里范围内后，比尔和雪莉选择离开房产。当他们收拾汽车时，他们儿子中 49 岁的科林（Colin）开车来到了房子前。
He was intent on protecting his parents' home and refused his father's request to leave. Colin was soon joined by his younger brother, 47-year-old David. Both men were experienced in fighting fires. David had been a member of the Country Fire Authority for 25 years and was considered very, very competent when it came to firefighting. While Colin had been a lieutenant in the Queensland Fire Service. After their parents had left, the brothers spent the afternoon hosing down the house, flooding the gutters with water, dampening cushions on the veranda, hanging wet towels over the windows and filling everything they could with water. They phoned family members as they worked, telling them that they were safe, that the fire was not close by, and that they would leave shortly.
他一心想要保护父母的家，并拒绝了他父亲离开的要求。科林很快与他的弟弟、47 岁的大卫（David）汇合了。两人都有丰富的人消防经验。大卫已经加入乡村消防局 25 年，在消防方面被认为非常、非常能干，而科林曾是昆士兰消防服务局的中尉。在父母离开后，兄弟俩整个下午都在用水管给房子浇水，用水淹没排水沟，弄湿阳台上的垫子，把湿毛巾挂在窗户上，并用能装满水的所有东西装满水。他们在工作时给家人打电话，告诉他们他们很安全，火离得不远，他们很快就会离开。
In a call to his mother, David reassured her, the house is safe mum, don't worry about it, and told her he loved her before hanging up. At 3.30pm, David spoke over the phone with a police officer stationed at a nearby roadblock, who warned him to expect very strong winds that could produce very dangerous conditions. David contacted his son at around 6pm to report that the fire had passed, although he also mentioned, quote, something about a wind change. It arrived 15 minutes later. Early the following morning, Colin and David Gibson's bodies were found in their parents' destroyed house. The only possible escape route had been the 200 metre driveway to the main road, which at the time of their deaths had led directly into the fire.
大卫在给母亲的电话中安慰她：“妈妈，房子很安全，别担心，”并在挂断电话前告诉她他爱她。下午 3 点 30 分，大卫与驻扎在附近路障的一名警官通了电话，警官警告他预计会有非常强的风，这可能会产生非常危险的状况。大卫在下午 6 点左右联系了他的儿子，报告说大火已经过去，尽管他也提到“关于风向转变的一些事情”。15 分钟后它就到了。第二天清晨，科林和大卫·吉布森的尸体在他们父母被毁的房子里被发现。唯一的可能逃生路线是通往主路的 200 米长车道，在他们死亡时，这条车道直接通向大火。
51-year-old Alan Jacobs and his 50-year-old wife Miros lived in a brick veneer house with a corrugated iron roof, situated in a densely-treated area of Cornala. Their remote, sloped property backed onto a creek and was described by a neighbour as the most beautiful little valley you could ever live in. Alan and Miros had been married for 30 years and had two sons, one of whom was overseas. Their fire plan was to stay and defend their property, which was equipped with independent power, several sources of water and firefighting equipment. They were prepared to take shelter in a workshop garage positioned beneath their house and wait for the fire front to pass, then emerged to extinguish any remaining spotfires.
51 岁的阿兰·雅各布斯（Alan Jacobs）和他的 50 岁妻子米罗斯（Miros）住在科纳拉（Cornala）一个树木密集的区域内，这是一栋带波纹铁皮屋顶的砖饰面房屋。他们偏远、倾斜的房产背靠一条小溪，被邻居描述为“你能住过的最美丽的小山谷”。阿兰和米罗斯已经结婚 30 年，有两个儿子，其中一个在海外。他们的防火计划是留下来保卫他们的房产，该房产配备了独立电源、多个水源和消防设备。他们准备躲在位于他们房子下方的作坊车库里避难，等待火锋过去，然后出来扑灭任何剩余的飞火。
The workshop was accessed via a roller door and had a concrete base and ceiling with double brick walls and a large window at one end covered in a steel shutter. On February 7, 2009, Alan and Miros were joined by their son Luke and his friend Nathan Charles, both aged 21. They, along with several of their friends, spent the afternoon preparing the Jacobs home for the fire. The fire front was just over the hill, but based on the blazer's migration, it was only expected to skim the edge of the property. Nevertheless, discussions were held in relation to staying or evacuating. Alan Jacobs told the others that the choice was theirs, but the garage would be a safe haven for those who remained behind. By 6pm, almost everyone had left or was leaving.
车库通过卷帘门进入，拥有混凝土底座和天花板以及双砖墙，一端有一扇大窗户，上面盖着钢制百叶窗。2009 年 2 月 7 日，阿兰和米罗斯与他们的儿子卢克（Luke）以及他的朋友内森·查尔斯（Nathan Charles）汇合，两人都是 21 岁。他们和他们的几个朋友一起，整个下午都在为雅各布斯家抵御火灾做准备。火锋就在山的那头，但根据大火的移动轨迹，预计它只会擦过房产的边缘。尽管如此，大家还是就留下还是撤离进行了讨论。阿兰·雅各布斯告诉其他人，选择权在他们自己，但对于留下的人来说，车库将是一个安全的避风港。到了下午 6 点，几乎所有人都已经离开或正在离开。
Nathan Charles was the only person who decided to stay behind with Alan, Miros and Luke Jacobs. The wind changed soon after, and at 6.44pm, Nathan placed a call to triple zero, explaining that the house was on fire and that they were trapped. He then phoned his father and sounded as though he was saying goodbye, but the call dropped out. Nathan's father then received a text from his son that read, Dad, I'm dead. I love you. The fire destroyed the Jacobs carport, cars, boat and almost the entire house. The bodies of Alan, Miros and Luke Jacobs and Nathan Charles were found the following day inside the garage, which remained intact. A forensic scientist concluded,
内森·查尔斯是唯一一个决定与阿兰、米罗斯和卢克·雅各布斯留下来的人。风很快就变了，在下午 6 点 44 分，内森拨打了三零（000）紧急电话，解释说房子着火了，他们被困住了。然后他给父亲打电话，听起来像是在道别，但电话挂断了。内森的父亲随后收到儿子发来的一条短信：“爸爸，我死了。我爱你。”大火摧毁了雅各布斯的车棚、汽车、船和几乎整栋房子。阿兰、米罗斯、卢克·雅各布斯和内森·查尔斯的尸体第二天在完好无损的车库内被发现。一位法医总结道：
With the doors closed tightly and the window shuttered, ventilation would be limited. In the circumstances, with carbon monoxide and deoxyde levels increasing and oxygen being consumed in the fire, ventilation could be a critical issue. All four victims had asphyxiated. Colligny resident Jenny lived in a single story house with her husband Glenn and their two young children. Although their property was bordered by bushland, it was clear of vegetation and trees. Jenny and Glenn's fire plan was to fire off any floating embers with their basic equipment and to leave if the situation worsened. In the early afternoon of February 7, 2009, Jenny dropped her children off at her in-laws and returned home to her husband. She hoped her mother, 51-year-old Annette Lethem would stay in the comfort of her home as she had an autoimmune disease that limited her ability to move quickly.
随着门紧闭且窗户百叶窗关闭，通风将受到限制。在这种情况下，一氧化碳和二氧化碳水平不断上升，火灾中氧气被消耗，通风可能成为一个关键问题。所有四名受害者都因窒息而死亡。科利尼（Colligny）居民珍妮（Jenny）与她的丈夫格伦（Glenn）和他们的两个幼儿住在一栋单层房屋里。虽然他们的房产周围环绕着林地，但那里没有植被和树木。珍妮和格伦的防火计划是用他们的基本设备扑灭任何漂浮的余烬，如果情况恶化就离开。2009 年 2 月 7 日下午早些时候，珍妮把孩子送到公公婆婆家，然后回到丈夫身边。她希望她的母亲、51 岁的安妮特·莱瑟姆（Annette Lethem）能留在家里安享舒适，因为她患有自身免疫性疾病，限制了她快速移动的能力。
However, at 5.30pm, Annette and her husband Rodney arrived at Jenny's house to help defend the property. They were aware of the smoke and strong winds, but the lack of embers and ash meant there was no indication they should be seriously concerned for their safety. Just before 6pm, Rodney received a call from his brother who warned him of the anticipated wind change. Neither Rodney nor Glenn understood the implications of this, with Glenn later stating, I had no idea that the fire front would be heading directly for us when the wind changed. Rodney and I both thought it would horseshoe around us. By 6.30pm, the power had gone out and the countryside was enveloped by a haunting red glow, prompting Jenny, Glenn, Rodney and Annette to discuss their options. When embers started swirling around the property at 7pm, the group decided to evacuate.
然而，下午 5 点 30 分，安妮特和她的丈夫罗德尼（Rodney）到达珍妮家帮忙保卫房产。他们意识到了烟雾和强风，但缺乏余烬和灰烬意味着没有迹象表明他们应该严重担心自己的安全。就在下午 6 点之前，罗德尼接到他兄弟的电话，警告他即将到来的风向转变。罗德尼和格伦都没有理解这意味着什么，格伦后来表示：“当风向改变时，我不知道火锋会直接朝我们袭来。罗德尼和我俩都以为它会绕着我们呈马蹄形刮过去。”到下午 6 点 30 分，电力中断，乡村被一种令人难忘的红光笼罩，促使珍妮、格伦、罗德尼和安妮特讨论他们的选择。当余烬在晚上 7 点开始在房产周围盘旋时，大家决定撤离。
Jenny and Glenn left in separate vehicles, with Rodney and Annette following behind in their yew. Within minutes, Cinder was raining down around them like red hot bullets. As Rodney drove, he was confronted by what he described as a massive, fast, furious grass fire. As the fire front rose over the hill and began raining thick black droplets onto his vehicle's windscreen. Surrounded by fire and unable to see clearly, Rodney tried to back the yew into a dam, but when it appeared to stall, his panicked wife decided to make a run for the house. Annette led them open to the passenger side door and leapt out, immediately falling into the fire. Rodney rushed to help, but was unable to save her.
珍妮和格伦乘不同的车辆离开，罗德尼和安妮特开着他们的皮卡车紧随其后。几分钟之内，煤渣就像红热的子弹一样在他们周围倾盆而下。当罗德尼开车时，他面对的是他所描述的一场巨大、快速、狂暴的草火。当火锋越过小山并开始将厚厚的黑色水滴倾泻到他汽车的挡风玻璃上时。被大火包围且视线不清，罗德尼试图将皮卡车倒进水库，但在车似乎抛锚时，他惊慌失措的妻子决定跑向房子。安妮特带头打开副驾驶侧的车门并跳了出去，立即掉进了火海中。罗德尼冲过去帮忙，但没能救下她。
Despite witnessing his wife's death and having sustained severe burns to 40% of his body, Rodney went on to battle several spot fires and managed to save his daughter's house. In September 2007, Martin Schultz and his wife Rachel relocated from Queensland to Victoria with their young son and settled into a house on Factory Road in Coligny. By 2009, Martin and Rachel had separated, but maintained an amicable relationship. Martin worked in a local brick factory and continued living at the Coligny property with his pet dog, Kelly. Martin was home alone on February 7, 2009, when his father-in-law called to inform him about the fire underway in Churchill. At around 3pm that day, a neighbour visited to warn Martin of the fire's proximity, estimating that it was only about 10km away.
尽管目睹了妻子的死亡，且身体 40% 遭受严重烧伤，罗德尼还是继续扑灭了几处飞火，并设法保住了女儿的房子。2007 年 9 月，马丁·舒尔茨（Martin Schultz）和他的妻子雷切尔（Rachel）带着他们的幼儿从昆士兰搬到维多利亚，并在科利尼的工厂路（Factory Road）定居下来。到 2009 年，马丁和雷切尔已经分居，但保持着友好关系。马丁在当地一家砖厂工作，继续带着他的宠物狗凯利（Kelly）住在科利尼的房产里。2009 年 2 月 7 日，马丁独自在家，他的岳父打电话通知他丘吉尔正在发生的火灾。那天下午 3 点左右，一位邻居来访，警告马丁注意火灾的接近，估计它距离只有 10 公里左右。
Martin was unaware of the danger. Although some smoke was visible, it was mostly obscured by a large ridge behind his house and there was no odor in the air. His father-in-law phoned a second time at about 4pm, telling him that the fire was moving in his direction and to prepare to leave. Martin responded that the fire was not there yet, but he was ready to go. An hour later, he spoke to his ex-wife Rachel, asking if she wanted him to pack anything in the car before he left the property. She pressed him to leave immediately, but Martin assured her that it wasn't that bad, as the fire wasn't there yet. Martin then spoke to his sister on the phone, who encouraged her brother to act intuitively, despite the Country Fire Authority's website deeming the area safe. She called back a short time later to warn him about the anticipated wind change.
马丁没有意识到危险。虽然可以看到一些烟雾，但大部分都被他房子后面的一座大山脊遮挡住了，空气中也没有异味。他的岳父在大约 4 月 4 点钟第二次打电话，告诉他火正朝着他的方向移动，并让他准备离开。马丁回答说火还没到，但他已经准备好走了。一个小时后，他与前妻雷切尔通话，问她在他离开房产前是否想让他在车里打包什么东西。她催促他立即离开，但马丁向她保证情况没那么糟，因为火还没到。马丁随后在电话里和他的姐姐通了话，尽管乡村消防局的网站认为该地区是安全的，但姐姐还是鼓励她的弟弟凭直觉行事。她不久后回电话警告他关于预期的风向转变。
Martin told me if the wind came from the south, he was screwed and that he was going to leave. At 6.40pm, Martin phoned his ex-wife once more to tell her that he was in the car. Rachel recalled, I could hear the wind and the incredible roar, so it must have hit by then. I could hear fear and hurriedness in his voice. She instructed Martin to go to her father's house. 20 minutes later, a distressed Martin called his father-in-law and stated, There's a tree across the road and I'm on fire.
马丁告诉我，如果风从南方刮来，他就完蛋了，他打算离开。下午 6 点 40 分，马丁再次给他的前妻打电话，告诉她他在车里。雷切尔回忆说：“我能听到风声和令人难以置信的咆哮声，所以到那时它一定已经袭击了。我能听到他声音里的恐惧和仓促。”她指示马丁去她父亲家。20 分钟后，惊慌失措的马丁打电话给他的岳父，并说：“路上有棵树，我着火了。”
This was the last anyone heard from Martin Schultz and he was registered as a missing person the following day. Almost a week later, Martin's body, along with that of his dog, was found in his burnt-out car in a creek bed three kilometres from his home. Gertrude and Eric Martin immigrated to Australia from Germany in 1956, bringing with them their two children before having their third in Melbourne. In 1973, the Martins purchased the dilapidated old dairy farm on Jirilang North Road in Jirilang, then set about fixing up its weather board and cement sheet home. They added a wood grain extension and filled the surrounding garden with ornamental trees and shrubs. The pair worked on the farm for 30 years, but had recently settled down when Gertrude's health declined. At 80 years old, she suffered from a heart condition, high blood pressure and had trouble with her hips.
这是任何人听到马丁·舒尔茨的最后消息，他在第二天被登记为失踪人员。大约一周后，马丁的尸体以及他的狗的尸体在距离他家三公里处的一个河床里烧毁的汽车中被找到。格特鲁德（Gertrude）和埃里克·马丁（Eric Martin）于 1956 年从德国移民到澳大利亚，带着他们的两个孩子，随后在墨尔本生下了第三个孩子。1973 年，马丁夫妇买下了吉里朗北路（Jirilang North Road）上一座破旧的旧奶牛场，然后着手修缮其木板和水泥板房屋。他们增加了一个木纹扩建部分，并在周围的花园里种满了观赏树木和灌木。这对夫妇在农场工作了 30 年，但最近随着格特鲁德健康状况恶化而安定下来。80 岁的她患有心脏病、高血压，并且髋关节有问题。
Eric was aware of the fire danger forecast for February 7, 2009 and spent the morning making final preparations to defend his home. At 2pm, a neighbour who lived 15 kilometres down the road phoned 000 to report that the fire was about a kilometre away from his property and heading towards the Martins. Police officers were tasked with conducting a welfare check on the elderly couple, however their notes did not specify a name or address, so it was not carried out. As Gertrude made lunch, Eric noticed grey and yellow smoke in the air, which was soon accompanied by flames. He grabbed his pump to soak the exterior of their house, but the suction hose had already melted. Burning branches, sticks and leaves rained down onto the roof, while inside the home, heat and smoke radiated down the hallway into the kitchen. Realising there was no hope to defend their home, Eric guided Gertrude towards a rear door that led out to the back porch. When he opened the door, fire immediately shot inside, so he quickly slammed it shut, later explaining.
埃里克知道 2009 年 2 月 7 日的火灾危险预报，并花了一上午时间做最后准备来保卫他的家。下午 2 点，一位住在路下 15 公里处的邻居拨打 000 报警，报告说火距离他的房产约有一公里，正朝着马丁夫妇的方向前进。警察被指派对这对老年夫妇进行福利检查，然而他们的记录没有指明姓名或地址，因此没有执行。当格特鲁德做午饭时，埃里克注意到空气中有灰色和黄色烟雾，随后很快伴随着火焰。他抓起水泵浸泡房屋外墙，但吸水管已经融化。燃烧的树枝、树棍和树叶如雨点般落在屋顶上，而屋里，热浪和烟雾顺着走廊直逼厨房。意识到保卫家园无望，埃里克引导格特鲁德走向通往后门廊的后门。当他打开门时，火立刻冲了进来，于是他迅速将其“砰”地关上，后来解释道：
I don't know how long we waited, but the house was burning and everything around us was burning. After a minute or two, I tried the door again and the flames were totally gone. When the blaze subsided, Eric led Gertrude outside into the fence line, where she expressed a need to rest and settled down by a fence post. Eric placed a wet towel over his wife's head and headed back to the house to extinguish several spot fires. Upon returning to Gertrude minutes later, he found her lying on the ground as though she was sleeping. Eric held her hand, only to realise she had passed away. It was later determined that Gertrude Martin had died as a result of a heart attack. You know that feeling of getting lost in a story you're listening to?
“我不知道我们等了多久，但房子在燃烧，我们周围的一切都在燃烧。一两分钟后，我再次试着开门，火焰已经完全消失了。”当火势减弱时，埃里克领着格特鲁德走到栅栏线外的外面，她表示需要休息，并在一个栅栏桩旁坐了下来。埃里克在妻子头上盖了一条湿毛巾，然后返回房子扑灭几处飞火。几分钟后回到格特鲁德身边时，他发现她躺在地上，仿佛在睡觉。埃里克握住她的手，却意识到她已经过世了。后来确定格特鲁德·马丁死于心脏病发作。你知道那种沉浸在所听故事中的感觉吗？
The power to spark our imagination is what Audible is all about. Canadian voices reading best-selling audiobooks, podcasts and exclusive originals. Hey, it's Ross Weston from the Rossimoca Show podcast. Welcome to A Good Listen, with a new clip from a recommended title selected by our friends at Audible.ca. Take a good listen to Wildlife Confidential, hosted by Samantha Bee and Andrew Fung. On this episode, our story starts in Toronto, Canada. Gordo, just give me the facts. Toronto is the biggest city in Canada. It's filled with skyscrapers and people.
激发我们想象力的力量正是 Audible 的全部意义所在。加拿大之声朗读畅销有声书、播客和独家原创作品。嘿，我是罗斯·威斯顿（Ross Weston），来自《罗斯莫卡秀》播客。欢迎收听《好听》（A Good Listen），这里有我们 Audible.ca 的朋友们挑选的推荐作品的新片段。请好好听听由萨曼莎·比（Samantha Bee）和安德鲁·冯（Andrew Fung）主持的《野生动物机密》（Wildlife Confidential）。在本集节目中，我们的故事从加拿大安大略省多伦多开始。戈多，只给我事实。多伦多是加拿大最大的城市。这里到处都是摩天大楼和人。
There's also a beautiful park there called High Park. It has big black oaks and cherry blossoms. And in the winter, kids go sledding in the snow. Fun! To hear more, join and listen for free for 30 days. Find this title and over 800,000 more at Audible.ca. There's more to imagine with Audible. Hey friends, Kaylin here from Teach Me How to Adult, and we talk a lot on our show about how to live your best life
那里还有一个美丽的公园叫海伊公园（High Park）。里面有巨大的黑橡树和樱花。冬天，孩子们在雪地里滑雪橇。真有趣！要收听更多内容，请加入并免费收听 30 天。请在 Audible.ca 寻找此标题以及其他 80 万首作品。与 Audible 一起，有更多值得想象的事情。嘿，朋友们，我是来自《教我如何成为成年人》（Teach Me How to Adult）的凯琳（Kaylin），我们在节目中经常讨论如何过上最好的生活，
while also balancing being a financially responsible human. So, if you've been dreaming of that epic vacation or you want to explore a new city while still keeping your bills at bay, listen up, because we've teamed up with Airbnb to share some ways on how you can easily become an Airbnb host. So when we took the big leap into adulthood and bought our first home, we purposely looked for a place that we could Airbnb whenever we're on vacation or just if we want to try working out of a different city
同时还要平衡做一个对财务负责任的人。所以，如果你一直梦想着那场史诗般的假期，或者你想探索一个新城市，同时还能控制好账单，请听好，因为我们已经与 Airbnb 合作，分享一些如何轻松成为 Airbnb 房东的方法。所以当我们迈出成年人的大步买下第一套房子时，我们特意寻找了一个地方，以便我们在度假时或者只是想尝试在不同的城市办公时，都可以将其在 Airbnb 上出租，
because we both work from home and we love traveling. And it's honestly the perfect way to have the freedom and flexibility to travel or just go wherever you want while giving you that second stream of income and covering your cost while you're away. And you don't need a mansion or an entire floor of your home. It could honestly be as simple as just renting out a spare room or just occasionally doing it if you are traveling for a little bit. You could honestly be sitting on an Airbnb and not even know it.
因为我们都在家办公，而且我们喜欢旅游。这老实说是一种完美的方式，既能拥有旅游的自由和灵活性，或者只是去你想去的任何地方，同时又能为你提供第二收入来源，并在你外出时支付你的费用。你不需要豪宅或家里的整层楼。老实说，它可以像出租一个空房间或偶尔在你出差一段时间时这样做一样简单。你可能正坐在一个 Airbnb 上却甚至不知道这一点。
So whether you could use a little extra money to cover some bills or for something a little more fun, your home or spare room might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at Airbnb.ca forward slash host. Victoria police's arson squad began looking into the Churchill fire, dubbing their investigation Operation Winston. The first call to emergency services on Saturday, February 7, indicated that the fire had started at around 1.30 p.m.
因此，无论你是需要一点额外的钱来支付一些账单，还是为了更有趣的事情，你的家或空房间的价值可能比你想象的要高。请访问 Airbnb.ca/host 了解具体价值。维多利亚州警察的纵火调查组开始调查丘吉尔大火，将他们的调查命名为“温斯顿行动”（Operation Winston）。2 月 7 日星期六对紧急服务的第一通电话表明，火灾发生在下午 1 点 30 分左右，
with witness reports isolating its origin to somewhere near Glendonald Road and Jelloph's Outlet, around four kilometers southeast of Churchill's Town Centre. Local wildfire investigator from the Department of Sustainability and Environment, Ross Pridgen, had examined the scene the day after the blaze. First responders had reported two parallel fires burning in the area before they connected into one catastrophic inferno. Pridgen was able to isolate exactly where the two fires had met, and after inspecting the location for an hour,
目击者报告将火源锁定在格伦唐纳德路和杰利夫出口附近某处，距离丘吉尔镇中心东南约四公里。可持续发展与环境部的当地野火调查员罗斯·普里德根（Ross Pridgen）在大火发生后第二天检查了现场。第一响应者曾报告说，该地区有两处平行的火灾在燃烧，然后它们连接成了一场灾难性的烈火。普里德根能够准确隔离这两处火灾相遇的地方，在检查该位置一小时后，
he had calculated the origin point for each. They had ignited 100 metres apart on either side of Jelloph's Outlet. The first started amongst the dry brush and bracken within the surrounding plantation. The second had arisen from a pile of discarded junk that included old tyres, mattresses and faulty bicycles, none of which were capable of self-igniting. All scenarios, including that the fires had been caused by car exhausts, campfires, broken glass, lightning strikes or discarded cigarettes,
他计算出了各自的起火点。它们在杰利夫出口两侧相距 100 米处点燃。第一处起火点始于周围种植园内的干燥灌木丛和蕨类植物中。第二处则源于一堆废弃的垃圾，其中包含旧轮胎、床垫和故障自行车，这些东西没有一个是能够自燃的。所有设想，包括火灾是由汽车尾气、营火、碎玻璃、雷击或丢弃的烟头引起的，
were explored and ultimately rejected. The possibility that embers from one fire had started the other was also ruled out, as both blazes arose in quick succession and it typically takes upwards of 15 to 20 minutes for such spreading to occur. Additionally, a stray ember from the first fire would have had to travel backwards than sideways against strong winds to start the second. Arson detectives were certain the Churchill fire had been deliberately lit. Although no evidence of any improvised or delayed incendiary devices
都得到了探讨并最终被排除。一处火灾的飞火引发另一处火灾的可能性也被排除，因为这两场大火相继迅速爆发，这种蔓延通常需要长达 15 到 20 分钟的时间才会发生。此外，第一场火灾的飞火必须逆着强风向后然后横向移动才能引发第二场火灾。纵火侦探确信丘吉尔大火是人为故意点燃的。尽管没有任何临时或延迟燃烧装置的证据
or flammable liquids was uncovered at the origin point, one fire expert claimed that something as simple as a lit match or cigarette lighter would be enough to cause the wildfire, even the dry condition of the forest, coupled with the hot, windy weather. Hancock Victorian Plantations, the timber company that owned the forest, had patrolled the area from the ground and sky throughout February 7 and hadn't reported anything suspicious. As the state was on high alert that day,
起火点处没有发现任何易燃液体，一位火灾专家声称，尽管森林天气干燥、炎热且多风，但像点燃的火柴或打火机这样简单的事物就足以引发森林大火。汉考克维多利亚种植园（Hancock Victorian Plantations）是一家拥有该森林的木材公司，他们在2月7日全天对该地区进行了地面和空中的巡逻，并没有报告任何可疑情况。由于当天全州处于高度戒备状态，
police had also been covertly surveilling known firebugs in the region, however, none had visited the scene of the crime. Although not an exact science, Arson profiling did offer investigators some insight into the type of person capable of carrying out such an act. According to one prominent model, the fire-setting intervention program for mentally disordered offenders, arsonists are typically male, unemployed or struggling in the workforce
警方还在该地区秘密监视了知名的纵火犯，然而，没有一人去过犯罪现场。虽然纵火犯画像并非一门精确的科学，但它确实为调查人员了解能够实施此类行为的人提供了线索。根据一个突出的模型，即针对精神失常违法者的纵火干预计划，纵火犯通常为男性、失业或在职场中苦苦挣扎、
from a disadvantaged background, exhibit poor social skills and have a family history marred with abuse and or addiction. Deliberately lit fires are more common in semi-rural bushland regions such as those within the Latrobe Valley where public transport was poor, incomes were low, youth unemployment was high and child abuse and neglect occurred at a higher rate per capita. Motive could have ranged from an act of revenge to a targeted attack or a random opportunity.
背景贫困、社交技能较差，且有遭受虐待或成瘾的家族史。蓄意纵火在拉特罗布谷（Latrobe Valley）等半乡村灌木林地区更为常见，那里的公共交通落后、收入低下、青年失业率高，且虐待和忽视儿童的人均发生率更高。动机可能从复仇行为、有目标的袭击到随机的机会不等。
As only 1% of arsonists are ever caught, the odds of solving the crime were stacked against Operation Winston. In response to Victoria Police confirming that they were investigating the work of an arsonist, Australia's Prime Minister Kevin Rudd remarked, What do you say about anyone like that? What do you say? I don't know. There's no words to describe it other than,
由于只有1%的纵火犯会被抓获，温斯顿行动（Operation Winston）破案的几率微乎其微。针对维多利亚州警方证实他们正在调查纵火犯行径的回应，澳大利亚总理凯文·陆克文（Kevin Rudd）评论道：“你对这样的人有什么好说的？你说什么好呢？我不知道。除了……外，没有任何词语可以形容它，
it's mass murder. While arson squad detective Senior Constable Paul Burdenchello was re-examining the crime scene, a weather board farmhouse on the top of a hill to the east caught his attention. He visited the homestead, which was just up the road from the property where brothers Colin and David Gibson had lost their lives. Liam Ferguson, a student aged in his early 20s, answered the door. Liam, along with members of his immediate and extended family,
这是大规模谋杀。”当纵火调查组高级警员保罗·伯登切洛（Paul Burdenchello）重新勘察犯罪现场时，东边山顶上的一座木板农舍引起了他的注意。他走访了这座宅邸，它就在科林（Colin）和大卫·吉布森（David Gibson）两兄弟丧生的那处房产的不远处。利亚姆·弗格森（Liam Ferguson）是一名二十出头的学生，他前来开门。利亚姆和他的直系及旁系亲属，
had managed to save their house, although the landscape around it was completely destroyed. Liam told Detective Burdenchello that he was defending an area of his property by himself on the evening of Black Saturday, when a man suddenly emerged from the fire and smoke. He was aged in his late 30s with a stocky build and had a, quote, The man was dressed in camouflage print clothing and heavy work boots carrying a small tank-colored terrier dog called Brocky. Liam presumed he was trying to escape the fire
设法保住了他们的房子，尽管周围的景物已被完全摧毁。利亚姆告诉伯登切洛警员，黑色星期六的傍晚，他正在独自保护自己房产的一部分，这时一个男人突然从火海和浓烟中走了出来。他三十多岁，身材敦实，引文略，“这个男人穿着迷彩服和重型工作靴，怀里抱着一只名叫布罗基（Brocky）的黄褐色小梗犬。”利亚姆猜测他是在试图逃离火灾，
until they fled into the house together, where the man stood calmly in the living room. Liam ordered him to call triple zero before returning outside to search for his father. Once the fire front had passed, the man helped Liam and his family hose down the area. Liam introduced himself as Brendan and said he had been in the area helping a friend and former colleague who lived close by named Peter Townsend. Brendan explained that his car had broken down along the road and expressed concern that if it was destroyed, insurers would only pay him $500, not enough money to replace it.
直到他们一起逃进屋里，那个男人平静地站在起诉室内。利亚姆命令他拨打紧急求救电话，然后回到外面去找他的父亲。火锋过境后，这个男人帮利亚姆和他的家人用水管冲洗了该地区。利亚姆自我介绍说他叫布伦丹（Brendan），并说他一直在该地区帮助一位住在附近的朋友兼前同事，名叫彼得·汤森（Peter Townsend）。布伦丹解释说他的车在路上抛锚了，并表示担心如果车被烧毁，保险公司只会赔偿他500美元，这根本不够买一辆新车。
Brendan was described as vague and only spoke when spoken to. At around 10pm, a fire truck arrived at the Ferguson house and the family asked the crew to take Brendan home as he made them feel uneasy. Liam gave Detective Burton cello a plastic bag that contained a camouflage print canvas hat that Brendan had left behind. He also recalled seeing a stationary sky blue Holden sedan on Glendonald Road on February 7. It was parked at an odd angle on the grassy verge as though the driver had pulled over suddenly and abandoned it.
据描述，布伦丹言辞含糊，并且只有在跟他说话时才开口。晚上10点左右，一辆消防车来到了弗格森家，家人要求消防队员把布伦丹送回家，因为他让他们感到不安。利亚姆给了伯登切洛警员一个塑料袋，里面装着布伦丹落下的一顶迷彩帆布帽。他还回忆起在2月7日看到一辆停在格兰唐纳德路（Glendonald Road）上的天蓝色霍顿（Holden）轿车。它以奇怪的角度停在草地上，就像司机突然把车停下并遗弃了它一样。
Liam's mother had also observed the car when she evacuated the area at 2pm, around half an hour after the fire had been lit. Another local had witnessed the Holden driving up and down the street in recent times and presumed it belonged to one of his neighbours. On February 7, he too saw it parked haphazardly on Glendonald Road as a man frantically tried to start its engine. Despite the man's efforts, the Holden had been left behind and was burnt by the fire with its upholstery, windows and tyres incinerated.
利亚姆的母亲在下午2点疏散该地区时也注意到了这辆车，当时距离起火大约半小时。另一位当地居民最近曾目击这辆霍顿轿车在街上开来开去，以为它属于他的某位邻居。2月7日，他也看到这辆车乱七八糟地停在格兰唐纳德路上，一个男人正拼命地想发动它的发动机。尽管那个男人付出了努力，霍顿车还是被留在了那里，并在大火中被烧毁，其内饰、车窗和轮胎都化为了灰烬。
According to one witness, the car's owner returned to the area the day after the blaze with a tow truck but was advised to leave the vehicle as it was part of a crime scene. He retorted, Don't start that shit. I came down to help a mate with the fires. The car was towed to Connelly's towing and panel beading in Morwell, just over 10km north of Churchill. When detectives visited the panel beaders to ask if they had recovered any vehicles from the fire zone, the shop owner said they had only picked up one.
据一位目击者称，大火过后的第二天，车主带着一辆拖车回到了该地区，但被劝告离开这辆车，因为它是犯罪现场的一部分。他反驳道：“少来这套。我是来帮朋友灭火的。”这辆车被拖到了丘吉尔（Churchill）以北10公里多一点莫威尔（Morwell）的康纳利拖车和钣金修理厂（Connolly's towing and panel beading）。当侦探们访问钣金修理厂询问他们是否从火灾区拖回过任何车辆时，店主说他们只接了一辆。
He showed detectives a burnt-out, colourless shell, which had once been a sky-blue 1974 H.J. Holden. They could barely decipher the damaged license plate, which read SLW 387. The towing receipt had been made out to a man named Brendan Sockalock, who lived on Sheoke Grove in Churchill. When detectives checked Brendan Sockalock's details, they learned that he was 39 years old and didn't have a criminal record. They decided to speak with Peter Townsend, the friend who Sockalock had allegedly visited on Black Saturday. Peter had previously worked with Sockalock at Monash University's Gippsland campus, where they were both employed as gardeners. On February 7, Peter and his wife were evacuating by car when they noticed Sockalock's abandoned Holden on Glen Donald Road. Despite Sockalock telling others that his reason for being in the area was to visit Peter, his vehicle was parked some distance from the Townsend's property and faced away from it.
他向侦探们展示了一个烧毁的、褪色的外壳，它曾经是一辆天蓝色1974款HJ霍顿汽车。他们勉强辨认出受损的车牌，上面写着SLW 387。拖车收据是开给一个名叫布伦丹·索卡洛克（Brendan Sockalock）的男人的，他住在丘吉尔的谢欧克格罗夫（Sheoke Grove）。当侦探们核对布伦丹·索卡洛克的详细信息时，他们得知他39岁，没有犯罪记录。他们决定与彼得·汤森（Peter Townsend）谈谈，也就是索卡洛克在黑色星期六声称拜访过的朋友。彼得以前曾与索卡洛克在莫纳什大学吉普斯兰（Gippsland）分校共事，他们当时都在那里担任园丁。2月7日，彼得和他的妻子开车疏散时，注意到索卡洛克被遗弃在格兰唐纳德路上的霍顿汽车。尽管索卡洛克告诉其他人他来到该地区的原因是拜访彼得，但他的车却停在离汤森家有一段距离的地方，并且车头背对著汤森家。
According to Peter, Sockalock had a poor reputation at their former workplace, where he was known to lie and make up stories to impress others. He was considered childish and would scare colleagues by leaping out of bushes or bins, poke snakes with sticks, and brag about tying cats tails together. He repeatedly stared and grunted at one female staff member, until she eventually resigned because she couldn't stand it any longer. In moments of anger, Sockalock would threaten to kill others and their families, but smiled as he did so, confusing his targets as to whether he was joking or not. Those who complained about his behavior often found their cars damaged or tools missing. Sockalock was never caught committing criminal acts, presumably because he knew the location of the campus' security cameras and avoided them accordingly. Sockalock worked at the university for 18 years, until in mid-2006, he was finally terminated following a dispute with his supervisor. The supervisor had put together a list of staff grievances regarding Sockalock, which included him following colleagues home and later informing them,
据彼得说，索卡洛克在他们以前的工作单位名声很差，众所周知他喜欢撒谎和编造故事来给别人留下深刻印象。他被认为很幼稚，会通过从灌木丛或垃圾桶里跳出来吓唬同事、用棍子戳蛇、吹嘘把猫的尾巴绑在一起等行为来恶作剧。他一再盯着一名女员工并冲她咕哝，直到她最终因无法忍受而辞职。在愤怒的时刻，索卡洛克会威胁要杀害其他人及其家人，但他在这样做时却面带微笑，这让他的目标对象们搞不清他是在开玩笑还是认真的。那些抱怨他行为的人经常发现自己的汽车遭到破坏或工具失踪。索卡洛克从未被抓到过实施犯罪行为，大概是因为他知道校园里安全摄像头的位置并刻意避开了它们。索卡洛克在大学工作了18年，直到2006年中期，在与主管发生争执后终于被解雇。主管整理了一份员工对索卡洛克的申诉清单，其中包括他跟踪同事回家并随后通知他们：
watch out, I know where you live, challenging the boyfriend of a female staff member to a duel, lifting the guard on his ride on muller to shower debris on colleagues and deliberately running over golf balls, causing them to shoot out at bystanders. Sockalock's neighbors were also unnerved by his behavior. They would hear him tinkering in his backyard shed while he listened to the children's television shows Bob the Builder and Thomas the Tank Engine. One woman noticed him leering over her fence, prompting her to hang up drapes to prevent him from seeing into her windows. The day after Black Saturday, Sockalock left a voicemail for Peter Townsend, in which he stated, Peter, it's Brendan, I tried to get up, see if you're alright, my car broke down in Glen Donald Road and it's torched now. Tried to get hold of you, but you were busy, I'll catch up with you later mate, hope you're safe and well. Peter also informed detectives that shortly before 2pm on the day of the fire, he saw Sockalock getting into a car belonging to a local woman named Natalie Turner.
“小心点，我知道你住哪，”向一名女员工的男友发出决斗挑战，抬起他的乘骑式割草机的防护罩向同事喷射碎屑，以及故意碾过高尔夫球使其弹射到旁观者身上。索卡洛克的邻居也对他的行为感到不安。他们会听到他在后院的棚子里捣鼓，同时听着儿童电视节目《建筑师巴布》（Bob the Builder）和《托马斯和他的朋友们》（Thomas the Tank Engine）。一名女子注意到他在她的篱笆上窥视，这促使她挂上了窗帘以防他看进她的窗户。黑色星期六的第二天，索卡洛克给彼得·汤森留了一条语音留言，他在其中说道：“彼得，我是布伦丹，我试图过去看看你是否安好，我的车在格兰唐纳德路抛锚了，现在被烧毁了。我试图联系你，但你很忙，老兄，我稍后再联系你，希望你安全安好。”彼得还告诉侦探，在火灾发生当天下午2点之前不久，他看到索卡洛克上了一辆属于当地一名叫娜塔莉·特纳（Natalie Turner）的女性的车。
Natalie had been with her parents that day, when she noticed the smoke and decided to flee the area with her partner and children at around 1.45pm. They drove along Glen Donald Road, where a blue Holden sedan slightly obscured their way. A dazed man stood alongside it with his small dog. Natalie and her partner offered him a lift, taking him all the way to his home in Churchill. During the drive he remarked, I hope my car doesn't burn. He repeated the comment when they dropped him off, before quickly adding, Oh, and I hope nobody gets hurt. Investigators obtained records from triple zero emergency services, which listed the telephone numbers and addresses of individuals who called them on Black Saturday.
娜塔莉那天和她的父母在一起，当她注意到浓烟时，决定在大约下午1:45与她的伴侣和孩子一起逃离该地区。他们沿着格兰唐纳德路开车，一辆蓝色的霍顿轿车稍微挡住了他们的去路。一个神情恍惚的男人和他的小狗站在车旁。娜塔莉和她的伴侣提出让他搭便车，把他一直送到他在丘吉尔的家。在车里，他评论道：“我希望我的车不会烧毁。”当他们送他下车时，他重复了这句话，然后迅速补充道：“哦，我希望没有人受伤。”调查人员获取了紧急求救电话（triple zero）的记录，上面列出了在黑色星期六拨打电话的个人的电话号码和地址。
It was discovered that the call placed to triple zero when the Churchill fire commenced, came from a phone belonging to Brendan Sockalock. On Thursday, February 12, five days after the fire, police arrived at Brendan Sockalock's modest brick veneer bungalow in Churchill, only to discover no one was home. A call to Sockalock's mobile phone revealed he was out delivering newspapers, a side job he had taken to supplement his income. Investigators caught up to him and placed him under arrest for arson. He responded, I didn't light any fires. A search of Sockalock's house uncovered matches in a bathroom, a lighter in his bedroom, the registration for his burnt out car, and a business card from Connolly's towing and panel beating in Morwell. His backyard was cluttered with junk furniture and electrical equipment that was scattered around patches of scorched earth. Investigators set up a camera for a video interview in the property and escorted Sockalock inside.
人们发现，丘吉尔火灾爆发时拨打紧急求救电话的电话，属于布伦丹·索卡洛克。2月12日星期四，即火灾发生五天后，警察来到布伦丹·索卡洛克位于丘吉尔的简陋砖木贴面平房，却发现家里没人。拨打索卡洛克的手机显示他正在外面送报纸，这是一份他为了增加收入而从事的兼职工作。调查人员追上了他，并以纵火罪将他逮捕。他的回应是：“我没有放火。”对索卡洛克房子的搜查在浴室里发现了火柴，在卧室里发现了打火机，有他烧毁汽车的登记证，以及一张来自莫威尔康纳利拖车和钣金修理厂的名片。他的后院塞满了杂乱的旧家具和电器设备，散落在几处被烧焦的土地周围。调查人员在屋内架设了一台摄像机进行视频采访，并将索卡洛克护送进去。
The footage captured the stocky man with short graying hair in an outfit consisting of a sweatshirt, shorts and long socks in varying shades of green. When asked to confirm his name, age and date of birth, Sockalock responded in a slow, disjointed manner while keeping his hands in his pockets and shifting awkwardly in place. He replied, Brendan, before pausing and pulling a face. He then stated, 30 something or rather. He answered the question, what's your mum's name? With mum. The detectives were perplexed by Sockalock's abrupt change in demeanor. Up until this point, he had spoken to them fluently and coherently, but as soon as the camera was on him, he acted obtuse. Sockalock pointed to a police officer outside and asked who the bad man was and continued to respond to questions in an indecipherable and childlike manner.
录像捕捉到了这个身材敦实、留着灰色短发的男人，他穿着一件运动衫、短裤和各种绿色调的长袜。当被要求确认他的姓名、年龄和出生日期时，索卡洛克以一种缓慢、语无伦次的方式回应，同时把手插在口袋里，在原地尴尬地挪动。他回答说：“布伦丹，”然后停顿了一下，做了一个鬼脸。接着他说道：“三十多岁什么的。”对于“你妈妈叫什么名字？”这个问题，他回答：“妈妈。”侦探们对索卡洛克神态的突然转变感到困惑。在此之前，他一直流利且连贯地与他们交谈，但一有摄像机对着他，他就开始装傻充愣。索卡洛克指着外面的一个警察，问谁是坏人，并继续以一种令人费解的、孩子气的方式回答问题。
He stated he couldn't remember what he had been arrested for and when it was made clear to him that it was in relation to the Churchill fire, specifically arson causing death, Sockalock replied, probably. Interviewing detective and head of the arson squad, senior sergeant Adam Shoesmith asked, does this all sound familiar or you're not sure? Sockalock responded, I don't really comprehend things too much, before adding, I'll say yes, just to make you happy. At this point, the interview was suspended, having only lasted six minutes. Investigators spoke with Brendan Sockalock's father, who revealed that his son had an acquired brain injury from birth. Sockalock was then escorted to the Morwell police station to await assessment from a specialist. During the ride, his demeanor changed yet again and he was back to being astute and lucid while also displaying a hint of arrogance.
他声称自己记不清因何被捕，当向他明确指出这与丘吉尔火灾有关，特别是导致死亡的纵火时，索卡洛克回答说：“大概吧。”负责讯问的侦探兼纵火调查组组长、高级警长亚当·苏史密斯（Adam Shoesmith）问道：“这一切听起来很熟悉，还是你不确定？”索卡洛克回答说：“我其实不太能理解事情，”接着补充道：“我会说是，只是为了让你高兴。”此时，讯问暂停了，因为只持续了六分钟。调查人员与布伦丹·索卡洛克的父亲进行了交谈，他透露他的儿子有先天性获得性脑损伤。随后，索卡洛克被护送到莫威尔警察局，等待专家的评估。在车程中，他的神态再次发生了变化，他又变得精明而清透，同时也流露出一丝傲慢。
He made snide comments to the driver, such as, Two hands on the wheel for beginners and asked, are you nervous mate? When it was placed inside an interview room and a tape recorder was switched on, Sockalock's manner of speaking once again became vague and simple. He said he couldn't remember his middle name and he would ramble incoherently to avoid answering direct questions. Detectives believed Sockalock was playing up his impairment and took a break from interviewing, when suddenly he announced, I want to start talking. Sockalock had described his actions on Saturday, February 7, 2009, explaining how he'd spent the morning shopping with his father, before the pair headed back to Churchill shortly after having lunch. Sockalock was driving his Holden, which was having issues in the heat and was on the cusp of stalling.
他对司机说了些尖刻的话，例如：“新手两手都要放在方向盘上，”并问：“老兄，你紧张吗？”当他被安置在讯问室内并打开录音机时，索卡洛克的说话方式再次变得含糊而简单。他说他记不清自己的中间名，并且会语无伦次地东拉西扯以回避直接回答问题。侦探们认为索卡洛克是在夸大他的智力损伤并暂停了讯问，突然他宣布：“我想开始说话了。”索卡洛克描述了他2009年2月7日星期六的行动，解释了他如何度过早晨，与父亲一起购物，两人吃过午饭后不久便返回丘吉尔。索卡洛克开着他的霍顿汽车，由于天气炎热，车子出了毛病，正处於熄火的边缘。
Before dropping his father off at home, Sockalock told him he planned to drive up into the hills to where his friend Peter Townsend lived. He returned home briefly to change into some heavy work boots, then visited a nearby petrol station to purchase a packet of Paul Maul Slim's green cigarettes. As he drove along Glendonald Road towards Peter's place, Sockalock lit a cigarette with a lighter. Due to the uneven surface of the road, his car vibrated, causing an ember from the cigarette to fall onto the car floor. Sockalock picked it up with a napkin, which he then tossed out the window. He claimed the ember caused the napkin to ignite. I noticed there was fire and I panicked and I called triple zero and I just tried to get away as quick as possible. Just panicked. Sockalock's car happened to break down further along Glendonald Road, leaving him stranded.
在送父亲回家之前，索卡洛克告诉父亲他打算开车上山去他的朋友彼得·汤森住的地方。他短暂回家换上了重型工作靴，然后去附近的加油站买了一包绿色包装的保罗·莫尔细支香烟（Paul Maul Slim's）。当他沿着格兰唐纳德路开向彼得的住处时，索卡洛克用打火机点燃了一支烟。由于路面不平，他的车震动起来，导致烟头掉到了车内地板上。索卡洛克用一张餐巾纸把它捡起来，然后把它扔出了窗外。他声称烟头点燃了餐巾纸。“我注意到有火，我惊慌失措，我打了紧急求救电话，我只想以最快速度逃跑。就是惊慌失措。”索卡洛克的车恰好在格兰唐纳德路较远的地方抛omod（抛锚），让他陷入了困境。
When firefighters arrived at the scene soon after, they noticed Sockalock, whom they did not recognize, staring at the growing blaze with his dog in his arms. They ordered him to leave the area, but he continued to watch the flames. Shortly after this, Natalie Turner and her partner pulled up and offered Sockalock a lift back into town. Upon returning home, Sockalock climbed onto the roof and watched the fire in the distance for a while. At around 4.30pm, he walked back towards Glendonald Road where he had left his car. He avoided the main roads, which were blocked off by police, instead moving through burning paddocks, where he was spotted by emergency responders who were left stunned by the sight of a man walking his dog amidst the fire. Sockalock claimed he visited Peter Townsend's home to check on him, but said his friend wasn't there.
当消防员不久后赶到现场时，他们注意到索卡洛克（他们并不认识他）怀里抱着狗，凝视着不断蔓延的大火。他们命令他离开该地区，但他仍然继续注视着火焰。在此之后不久，娜塔莉·特纳和她的伴侣把车停下，提出让索卡洛克搭便车回镇上。回到家后，索卡洛克爬上屋顶，看了一会儿远处的火灾。下午4:30左右，他步行回到了他留下汽车的格兰唐纳德路。他避开了被警察封锁的主干道，转而穿过燃烧的牧场，在那里他被紧急救援人员发现，救援人员对一个男人在火海中遛狗的情景感到震惊。索卡洛克声称他去拜访了彼得·汤森的家以查看他的情况，但说他的朋友不在家。
This assertion was denied by Peter, who told police that he was indeed home at the time, protecting his livestock. Sockalock then crossed the road to the Ferguson's property, where he remained for several hours. Sockalock told detectives that he hadn't been able to sleep properly since the fire and accepted that it was his fault that 11 people died. The interview concluded with Sockalock being asked if he had told anyone what he had done. He replied, No, cause they, people, would go and form a lynch thing and chop a person up, so I kept quiet. An examination of Sockalock's home computer revealed dozens of photographs of firefighters battling the blazes on Black Saturday. It was also discovered that he had sent an anonymous email to Crime Stoppers three days after the incident, which read,
彼得否认了这一说法，他告诉警察，他当时确实在家保护他的牲畜。索卡洛克随后穿过马路来到弗格森的房产，在那里呆了几个小时。索卡洛克告诉侦探，自从火灾发生以来，他一直无法安眠，并承认11人死亡是他的错。讯问结束时，索卡洛克被问及是否将自己做过的事告诉过任何人。他回答说：“没有，因为他们，那些人，会去搞私刑然后把人碎尸万段，所以我保持了沉默。”对索卡洛克家用电脑的检查显示，里面有几十张消防员在黑色星期六扑灭大火的照片。人们还发现，他在事件发生三天后向犯罪制止热线（Crime Stoppers）发送了一封匿名电子邮件，上面写着：
I saw a Department of Sustainability and Environment firefighter light a fire on the edge of the road as I went past. I'm scared the bad man will get me. He described the arsonist as driving a white four-wheel drive utility vehicle and deliberately lighting the fire on the edge of Glendonald Road. Investigators believed this report was an attempt to throw them off by identifying a false suspect. Sockalock appeared uneasy when informed that his computer was being examined and it was soon discovered that he had evidence of child abuse material on the device. Throughout his confession, Sockalock reverted to his child-like behavior and speech pattern. That night, a medical officer diagnosed him with the developmental disorder autism, which is characterized by restrictive and repetitive behavior and to difficulties with social interaction and communication.
“我路过时看到一名可持续发展与环境部（Department of Sustainability and Environment）的消防员在路边放火。我害怕坏人会抓我。”他描述纵火犯开着一辆白色的四轮驱动多用途车，并且故意在格兰唐纳德路边缘放火。调查人员认为，这份报告是企图通过确定一个虚假的嫌疑人来转移他们的视线。当被告知他的电脑正在被检查时，索卡洛克显得局促不安，不久后人们便发现该设备上有虐待儿童材料的证据。在整个供认过程中，索卡洛克恢复了他孩子气的行为和说话模式。那天晚上，一名军医诊断他患有发育障碍孤独症，其特征是限制性和重复性行为，以及社交互动和沟通困难。
Autism is thought to cover a broad spectrum with some diagnosed individuals experiencing severe impairments, while others function at a higher level with less debilitating symptoms. Sockalock was also found to have a borderline intellectual disability. Brendan Sockalock spent the remainder of the night in police custody. The following day, he was escorted to Jelliff's outlet for a filmed field interview. Standing amongst the charred forest, Sockalock fidgeted and diverted his gaze, while again describing how he had started the fire by throwing a napkin containing a cigarette ember out of his car window. Detectives were aware that the Churchill fire emerged from two glazes that had been led in quick succession along Jelliff's outlet.
人们认为孤独症涵盖了广泛的谱系，一些被诊断出的人会经历严重的障碍，而另一些则在较高的水平上运作，症状较轻。人们还发现索卡洛克患有边缘性智力障碍。布伦丹·索卡洛克在警察拘留所度过了当晚剩下的时间。第二天，他被护送到耶利夫斯Outlet（Jelliff's outlet）进行拍摄的实地采访。站在烧焦的森林中，索卡洛克坐立不安，视线游移，同时再次描述了他如何通过将装有烟头的餐巾纸扔出车窗来引发火灾。侦探们知道，丘吉尔火灾是由沿着耶利夫斯Outlet接连被点燃的两处火情汇聚而成的。
Yet Sockalock maintained that he had only started one and it was unintentional. I didn't mean any of this to happen. I had no intention of this all to happen. Now I have to put up with it for the rest of my life and it makes me sad. Police were skeptical of Sockalock's story. When they spoke with other members of the Churchill community, they discovered that many viewed Sockalock as a cunning and disturbed individual. Sockalock had also harboured a fascination with fire from a young age. As a teen, he'd bragged about lighting a fire in the toilet of a local milk bar and another in a park. Sockalock later joined the country fire authority before it became mandatory for volunteers to undergo police checks with one family friend telling police.
然而索卡洛克坚称他只点燃了一处，而且是无意的。“我不是故意让这一切发生的。我根本无意让这一切发生。现在我必须在余生中忍受这一切，这让我很难过。”警方对索卡洛克的故事持怀疑态度。当他们与丘吉尔社区的其他成员交谈时，他们发现许多人认为索卡洛克是一个狡猾且精神失常的人。索卡洛克从小就对火有着迷恋。青少年时期，他曾吹嘘自己在当地一家牛奶店的厕所和一个公园里放火。索卡洛克后来加入了乡村消防局（country fire authority），当时志愿者接受警方背景调查还不是强制性的，一位家庭朋友告诉警方：
He loved the fire trucks and the power of being a hero. However, he was dismissed within the year, then twice prevented from rejoining due to suspicions that he was deliberately setting fires. According to the book The Arsonist, a Mind on Fire by true crime author Chloe Hooper, a CFA captain reported that Sockalock had admitted to starting fires so he could go out on the truck and help fight them. Days after the Churchill fire, Sockalock gave several explanations to others as to why he was in the vicinity of the blaze at the time it started, including that he was attending a wedding, visiting a friend and going to get a chisel back from an acquaintance. In one conversation, he described how a cigarette burning down to a fuel source would provide enough time for an arsonist to flee. Questions were raised about Sockalock's mental capacity. A former colleague described him as the most cunning person he had ever met, stating, I am aware that he may have a mental impairment of sorts, though he uses this to his own advantage. Brenton is a smarter person than what people give him credit for.
“他热爱消防车以及作为一个英雄的权力。”然而，他在一年内被解雇，随后两次因涉嫌蓄意纵火而被禁止重新加入。根据真实犯罪作家克洛伊·胡珀（Chloe Hooper）的书《纵火犯：燃烧的心灵》（The Arsonist, a Mind on Fire），一名消防局长报告说，索卡洛克曾承认自己放火，这样他就可以开着消防车出去帮忙灭火。丘吉尔火灾发生几天后，索卡洛克向其他人提供了关于他起火时为何在该地区附近的几种解释，包括他去参加婚礼、拜访朋友以及去向熟人取一把凿子。在一次谈话中，他描述了一支香烟烧到燃料源将如何为纵火犯逃跑提供充足的时间。人们对索卡洛克的精神能力提出了质疑。一位前同事形容他是自己见过最狡猾的人，并表示：“我知道他可能有某种精神障碍，但他利用这一点为自己谋利。布伦顿（Brenton）比人们给予他的评价更聪明。”
This characterization was also supported by Sockalock's brother, who shared his opinion with police. Peter Townsend claimed he once said to Sockalock, You don't seem too dumb to me. Prompting Sockalock to explain how he was occasionally assessed and would slobber, dribble and talk nonsense so that his assessors would believe he qualified for disability benefits. Sockalock travelled through the Latrobe Valley collecting scrap metal, which had, according to one local, given him a real geographical talent for navigating the region's back streets, fire access roads and dirt tracks. He burnt the excess junk he accumulated in his backyard, with neighbors stating that Sockalock's bonfires had been getting progressively bigger. Although no one witnessed Brenton Sockalock lighting the Churchill fire on Black Saturday, there were approximately 160 witnesses who had information regarding his movements on the day. Senior Constable Paul Burden-Cello later stated, Every one of them delivered a very, very strong circumstantial case.
这种性格特征也得到了索卡洛克兄弟的支持，他与警察分享了自己的看法。彼得·汤森声称他曾对索卡洛克说：“在我看来你并不那么笨。”这促使索卡洛克解释他是如何偶尔接受评估的，并且会流口水、流涎并说胡话，以便他的评估人员相信他符合残疾福利的资格。索卡洛克在拉特罗布谷四处收集废金属，据一位当地人说，这赋予了他熟练掌握该地区小巷、消防通道和土路的地理才能。他在后院焚烧积累的过剩垃圾，邻居们表示索卡洛克的篝火越烧越大。尽管没有人目击布伦顿·索卡洛克在黑色星期六点燃丘吉尔火灾，但大约有160名目击者掌握了他当天行踪的信息。高级警员保罗·伯登切洛（Paul Burden-Cello）后来表示：“他们每个人都提供了非常、非常强有力的间接证据链。”
Brenton Sockalock was charged with 10 counts of arson causing death, more than 180 counts of recklessly causing serious injury and damage, and charges related to the possession of child abuse material. He was not charged with the death of 80-year-old Gertrude Martin, as it was difficult to prove whether her heart attack was caused by a pre-existing health condition, or was a direct result of the fire. Despite the charges, Sockalock maintained his story that he never intended to start the Churchill fire, and that it was an accident. Due to the level of public anger over the case, Sockalock's defense barrister fought to suppress his identity. A magistrate agreed to ban the publication of Sockalock's photograph and address to protect him and his family from retribution, but ruled that Sockalock's name be made public. Those suspected of vigilantism would not be prevented from behaving in an abhorrent way, simply by suppressing his name. As the magistrate predicted, vigilantes were undeterred by the prospect of a suppression order, and were quick to name and shame.
布伦顿·索卡洛克被指控犯有10项纵火导致死亡罪、180多项鲁莽导致严重伤害和破坏罪，以及与持有虐待儿童材料相关的罪名。他没有被指控对80岁的老人格特鲁德·马丁（Gertrude Martin）的死负责，因为很难证明她的心脏病发作是由既往健康状况引起的，还是火灾的直接结果。尽管面临指控，索卡洛克仍然坚称自己从无意引发丘吉尔火灾，这是一场意外。由于公众对该案的愤怒程度，索卡洛克的辩护大律师力争隐去他的身份。一名地方法官同意禁止公开发布索卡洛克的照片和地址，以保护他和他的家人免受报复，但裁定索卡洛克的姓名予以公开。涉嫌私刑正义的人不会仅仅因为隐藏他的名字而停止做出令人发指的行为。正如法官所预测的那样，私刑实施者并没有被禁止令的前景吓退，并且很快就指名道姓地进行谴责。
A website titled Kill Brenton Sockalock was soon established, while members of a Facebook page called Brenton Sockalock Must Burn In Hell demanded that he be burned at the stake. Another online group offered $10,000 to whomever killed the alleged arsonist. For his own safety, Sockalock was relocated to a cell in the Melbourne Assessment Prison, and as the van carrying him pulled out of town, enraged locals pounded on the doors and yelled abuse. Prior to Sockalock's trial, the prosecution withdrew the 180-plus charges that pertained to recklessly causing serious injury and damage, in order to focus exclusively on the arson charges. They also dropped the charge relating to the child abuse material, as it couldn't be ascertained whether Sockalock had intentionally sought the images, or if, as he claimed, their data had been stored on his computer as cookies while he browsed the legal, adult pornography sites. In Australia, the charge of arson causing death carried a maximum penalty of 25 years in prison. Sockalock pleaded not guilty, and finally appeared in the Victorian Supreme Court almost three years after the Churchill fire. Various issues were debated throughout the trial, including Sockalock's mental state, whether the fire was accidental or deliberate, and if it was intentional, whether he had intended to kill.
一个名为“杀死布伦顿·索卡洛克”（Kill Brenton Sockalock）的网站很快建立起来，而一个名为“布伦顿·索卡洛克必须在地狱燃烧”（Brenton Sockalock Must Burn In Hell）的Facebook主页的成员则要求将他绑在火刑柱上烧死。另一个在线群体悬赏1万美元给杀死这名疑似纵火犯的人。为了他自身的安全，索卡洛克被转移到了墨尔本评估监狱（Melbourne Assessment Prison）的一个牢房里，当载着他的面包车驶离小镇时，愤怒的当地人砸着车门并大声叫骂。在索卡洛克受审之前，检方撤销了与鲁莽导致严重伤害和破坏有关的180多项指控，以便专门集中精力审理纵火指控。他们还放弃了与虐待儿童材料相关的指控，因为无法确定索卡洛克是有意搜寻这些图片，还是如他所说，当他在合法的成人色情网站上浏览时，这些数据作为Cookie存储在他的电脑上。在澳大利亚，纵火导致死亡罪的最高刑期为25年监禁。索卡洛克拒不认罪，并在丘吉尔火灾发生近三年后终于出庭维多利亚州最高法院。审判期间辩论了各种问题，包括索卡洛克的精神状态、火灾是意外还是蓄意的，以及如果是蓄意的，他是否蓄意杀人。
Motive was also considered, including whether Sockalock's poor treatment and reputation had compelled him to take revenge against his community, or if he had hoped to somehow control the situation and become a hero. It was also speculated whether he had falsely confessed to the crime, because he couldn't comprehend the gravity of the situation. Defence barrister Jane Dixon argued that the cause of the fire was unclear, and questioned how a forensic examination of the crime scene was even possible, given that the area had been disturbed by fire, helicopter bombing, bulldozing, raking, and waterhosing the day prior. She theorized that an unidentified motorcyclist witnessed in the area when the blaze started might have been responsible for the crime, but also put forth the possibility that it wasn't arson at all. Sockalock's troublesome hold on sedan was proposed as a possible cause, with a materials engineer testifying for the defence that embers from the car's exhaust pipe might have sparked the blaze. Dixon called Sockalock an easy target due to his autism. Sockalock's condition meant he experienced the difficulties with social interaction, verbal comprehension, and intellectual reasoning. As a child, he was severely bullied. When his parents collected him from the school bus, he was sometimes covered in spit and feces. He could barely read or write, and his parents withdrew him from school in year 11 after years of being tormented, struggling to make friends, and learning at a slower pace.
动机也被纳入考量，包括索卡洛克糟糕的待遇和名声是否迫使他对他的社区进行报复，或者他是否曾希望以某种方式控制局势并成为英雄。人们还推测他是否虚假供认了罪行，因为他无法理解局势的严重性。辩护大律师简·迪克森（Jane Dixon）辩称，火灾的原因并不明确，鉴于该地区在前一天已经遭到火灾、直升机轰炸、推土机推平、耙地和水枪冲洗的破坏，对犯罪现场进行法医检查又怎么可能做到呢。她推测，火灾发生时在现场目击的一名身份不明的摩托车手可能是这起犯罪的元凶，但也提出了根本不是纵火的可能性。索卡洛克那辆出问题的霍顿轿车被认为是潜在原因之一，一名材料工程师为辩护方出庭作证称，汽车排气管中的火星可能引发了火灾。迪克森称由于索卡洛克患有孤独症，他是一个容易下手的目标。索卡洛克的病情意味着他在社交互动、语言理解和智力推理方面遇到了困难。小时候，他遭到严重欺凌。当他的父母用校车接他时，他身上有时沾满了口水和粪便。他几乎不会读写，在经历多年折磨、难以交友以及学习进度较慢之后，他的父母在11年级时让他退了学。
Sockalock's recollections of his employment at Monash University varied to those of his colleagues, describing himself as their punching bag. The defence argued his condition had also led him to believe that he had something to do with the blaze, and explained why he kept changing his story. They alleged that police had used Sockalock as a scapegoat due to his reputation around town as a, quote, odd sort of fellow, and the stories implicating him as a fire bug were all hearsay. Dixon asserted that her clients called her triple zero to report the incident was not the action of a deliberate arsonist, and that he had been prosecuted by circumstantial evidence, stating, This was no contrived web of lies and deceit. He might have been pretty careless. He might have even been negligent, clumsy, uncoordinated, stupid. He's certainly not, in terms of autism, some rain man character. Frankly, Brendan Sockalock would not be capable of calculating his way out of a paper bag unless he had a map. A senior forensic psychologist who examined Sockalock was unable to ascertain a motive, and was of the opinion that he did not meet the criteria for a diagnosis of pyromania, concluding that, While Mr Sockalock does have several characteristics associated with fire setters, there are a number of important criteria lacking, the abuse of substances, general criminal offending, and antisociality.
索卡洛克对自己在莫纳什大学工作的回忆与同事们的说法有所不同，他形容自己是他们的出气筒。辩护方辩称，他的病情也导致他认为自己与这场大火有关，并解释了他为什么不断改变说词。他们声称，由于索卡洛克在镇上作为“怪人”的名声，警方将他当作了替罪羊，而暗示他是纵火犯的故事全都是传闻。迪克森断言，她的当事人拨打紧急求救电话报告事件并不是蓄意纵火犯的行为，并且他是被间接证据起诉的，并表示：“这不是一张虚构的谎言与欺骗之网。他可能相当粗心。他甚至可能疏忽大意、笨拙、不协调、愚蠢。就孤独症而言，他绝对不是什么雨人（Rain Man）角色。坦白说，如果布伦丹·索卡洛克没有地图，他连一张纸袋都走不出去。”一名检查过索卡洛克的资深法医心理学家未能确定动机，其观点认为他不符合病理性放火癖（pyromania）的诊断标准，并得出结论：“虽然索卡洛克先生确实具有与纵火犯相关的几个特征，但缺少了许多重要的标准，即滥用药物、一般刑事犯罪和反社会性。”
If he did deliberately light the fires, it is likely that his motivation was either expressive, as a result of his social inadequacy, or instrumental, to achieve a particular extrinsic goal. The prosecution argued that Sockalock's condition did not impact his mental understanding, and that he had become a person of interest just days after the fire based on witness testimony alone. They portrayed Sockalock as a calculating and cunning individual, describing how his demeanor changed depending on the circumstances, his varying stories as to why he was at the scene of the crime, and his attempt to blame a firefighter in an anonymous tip off to crime stoppers. The day after the fire, Sockalock had made a claim on his insurance policy in relation to his burnt out car, an act that indicated he had a high level of functioning. Multiple fire experts also gave evidence as to the difficulty and low probability that a cigarette ember crashed in a napkin, then tossed out a car window, could fuel a bushfire. They concluded that the fire could have only been lit in such a manner if the napkin was already burning when it was thrown out of the car. Prosecutor Ray Elston told the court, When the accused man arrives at that intersection, there is no fire. No one else is suggested to be present. When he leaves, it's a blaze.
如果他确实蓄意放火，他的动机很可能是发泄性的（由于他的社交能力不足），或者是工具性的（为了达到某种特定的外在目标）。控方辩称，索卡洛克的病情并未影响他的精神理解能力，且仅凭证人证词，他在火灾发生几天后就成为了受关注人员。他们将索卡洛克描绘成一个计算周密且狡猾的人，并描述了他的神态如何根据环境而改变、他关于为何身处犯罪现场的不同说法，以及他试图在给犯罪制止热线的匿名举报中嫁祸给一名消防员。火灾发生的第二天，索卡洛克就他烧毁的汽车提出了保险索赔，这一行为表明他具有很高的功能水平。多位火灾专家还就餐巾纸包裹烟头并扔出车窗引发森林大火的难度及极低概率提供了证据。他们的结论是，只有当餐巾纸被扔出车时已经处于燃烧状态，火灾才可能以这种方式被点燃。检察官雷·埃尔斯顿（Ray Elston）对法庭说：“当被告人到达那个十字路口时，没有火。没有其他人被认为在场。当他离开时，一片火海。”
All causes saved for deliberate ignition of this fire have been eliminated. There is only, therefore, one irresistible conclusion to draw from the totality of material, and to that is, the accused man set those fires at two points. When the 21 victim impact statements were read in court, Sockalock yawned and seemed unmoved by the stories he was hearing. Grant Jacobs shared his turmoil at being the sole remaining member of his family, stating, I have been left without my mother Miros, left without my father Alan, and my brother Luke, who was my best friend. It was done by someone's deliberate and ill-intentioned actions. The world has become a very lonely place. I just want my family back, which I know I can never have. Never. Grant's aunt Ronda spoke of the absolute annihilation of a family, and described crawling through the pile of ash that was once her brother's home for two and a half days, hoping to find anything that survived.
除了这起火灾是蓄意点燃的之外，所有其他原因均已被排除。因此，从全部材料中只能得出唯一不可抗拒的结论，那就是：被告人在两处地点放火。当21份受害者影响陈述在法庭上被宣读时，索卡洛克打了个哈欠，对听到的故事似乎无动于衷。格兰特·雅各布斯（Grant Jacobs）分享了他作为家中唯一幸存成员的痛苦，他说：“我失去了母亲米罗斯（Miros），失去了父亲阿兰（Alan），还有我的兄弟卢克（Luke），他是我最好的朋友。这是某人蓄意和恶意的行为所致。世界变得非常孤独。我只想找回我的家人，我知道我永远找不回来了。永远。”格兰特的姑姑朗达（Ronda）谈到了一个家庭的彻底毁灭，并描述了在曾经是她兄弟家的一堆灰烬中爬行了两天半，希望能找到任何幸存东西的经历。
Quote, I weep in the deepest places of my soul. Rodney Latham recalled his attempts to save his wife Annette, who was consumed by the fire in front of his eyes. He described feeling as though he was standing in the middle of a volcano and smelling his own flesh burning. Quote, I have a thousand what-ifs that I should have done this or I should have done that, and my wife would still be alive. He couldn't go out in the sun anymore as it caused his burn scars to itch painfully. Lachlan Frando was six years old when the fire took the life of his father, Scott, and grandfather, Alfred. He said he missed them every day and that Sokolok took away his life and family. A video tribute to the victims was played in court, which Sokolok watched briefly before returning to his pens and paper that he had been using to scribble with throughout the trial.
引文：“我在灵魂最深处哭泣。”罗德尼·拉瑟姆（Rodney Latham）回忆了他试图拯救妻子安妮特（Annette）的经历，安妮特在他的眼前被大火吞噬。他描述自己当时感觉就像站在火山正中间，并闻到了自己肉体燃烧的味道。引文：“我有成千上万个‘如果当初’，我本该这样做，或者我本该那样做，我的妻子现在就会还活着。”他再也不能晒太阳了，因为这会导致他的烧伤疤处奇痒无比。拉克兰·弗兰多（Lachlan Frando）在火灾夺走他的父亲斯科特（Scott）和爷爷阿尔弗雷德（Alfred）的生命时只有六岁。他说他每天都在想念他们，索卡洛克夺走了他的生活和家人。法庭播放了一段对受害者的致敬视频，索卡洛克短暂地看了看，然后又回到了他在整个审判过程中用来乱涂乱画的笔和纸上。
After four days of deliberation, the jury found Brendan Sokolok guilty of 10 counts of arson causing death. Justice Paul Coglan told Sokolok, I am satisfied beyond reasonable doubt for the purposes of sentencing that you intentionally lit the fire, intending to set fire to eucalypt plantations. I am also satisfied that you lit the fire at two distinct places at or near the intersection of Jellif's Outlet and Glen Donald Road. The event was terrifying for all involved in the fires, whether directly or otherwise. Death from natural disaster would be bad enough, but their suffering is significantly increased from knowing that the fire which caused the death was deliberately lit. For the victims, these were and are life-changing events, and to no sentence that I impose can in any way compensate for their loss. But it does bring to an end one part of the process.
经过四天的审议，陪审团裁定布伦丹·索卡洛克10项纵火导致死亡罪名成立。法官保罗·科格兰（Paul Coglan）对索卡洛克说：“为了量刑，我确信毫无合理怀疑，你蓄意纵火，意图烧毁桉树种植园。我也确信你在耶利夫斯Outlet与格兰唐纳德路交叉口或附近的两个不同地点放火。对于所有卷入火灾的人来说，无论是直接还是其他方式，这起事件都是骇人听闻的。因自然灾害死亡已经够糟糕了，但得知导致死亡的火灾是蓄意点燃的，他们的痛苦大大增加了。对受害者而言，这些过去是、现在也是改变生活的大事，我所判处的任何刑罚都无法以任何方式补偿他们的损失。但它确实为一个阶段的审判画上了句号。”
Though Justice Coglan accepted that Sokolok had not set out to kill anyone, he referenced the defendant's training with the country fire authority, which provided him with the knowledge that his actions came with certain risks, including damage and death. Taking into account his impaired mental functioning, which Judge Coglan believed reduced his moral culpability, Brendan Sokolok was sentenced to 17 years and 9 months in jail, with a non-parole period of 14 years. The guilty verdict made Sokolok the state's worst mass killer. In March 2013, the director of public prosecutions appealed the length of Sokolok's sentence on the basis that it was manifestly inadequate and sought an increase to 24 to 26 years. They were concerned that offered little deterrence to would-be arsonists, especially those in bad or challenging circumstances. In their unanimous ruling rejecting the application, the court of appeal said that while the gravity of the offence was an important sentencing factor, Sokolok's disability had to be considered.
尽管科格伦法官承认索洛克并没有蓄意杀害任何人，但他提到了被告在维州乡村消防局接受过的培训，这让他清楚地知道自己的行为伴随着某些风险，包括财产损失和人员伤亡。综合考虑其受损的精神功能——科格伦法官认为这降低了他的道德罪责，布伦丹·索洛克被判处17年9个月监禁，不得假释期为14年。这一有罪判决使索洛克成为该州最严重的群体杀人犯。2013年3月，公共检控官对索洛克的刑期提出了上诉，理由是判决明显过轻，并寻求将刑期增加到24至26年。他们担心这无法对潜在的纵火犯起到足够的威慑作用，尤其是那些处境恶劣或面临艰难环境的人。上诉法院在一致驳回该申请的裁决中表示，尽管犯罪的严重性是量刑的一个重要因素，但必须考虑索洛克的残疾情况。
Quote, Our law does not treat an offender with an intellectual disability or other mental impairment in the same way as an offender who does not have such a disability. The moral culpability of a person who intentionally lights a fire on a day of extreme weather conditions, and or in the face of a total fire ban, appreciating there is a strong possibility that the fire will spread, is greater than the moral culpability of a person who does not understand the magnitude of that risk. Sentencing principles require the court to consider the effect which his or her mental condition had on his or her moral culpability. In our view, the sentences imposed after weighing these factors fell within the reasonable exercise of the judge's discretion. A royal commission was held into the Black Saturday fires, which aimed to examine all aspects of the government's bushfire strategy. It began prior to Brendan Sokolok's trial, and therefore did not address his involvement in the Churchill fire. Instead, focusing on the experiences and reactions of emergency services personnel and victims before, during, and after the blaze. The commission acknowledged numerous examples of courage, initiative, and professionalism that increased community and firefighter safety, protected houses and property, and supported local crews who were both fighting the fires and risking their own homes and businesses.
引述：“我们的法律对待患有智力障碍或其他精神障碍的罪犯，与对待没有这种障碍的罪犯的方式不同。一个人在极端天气条件下和/或在全面禁火令生效期间故意点燃一场火灾，并且意识到火灾蔓延的可能性很大，其道德罪责要大于一个不理解该风险严重程度的人。量刑原则要求法院考虑其精神状况对其道德罪责产生的影响。在我们看来，权衡这些因素后作出的判决符合法官自由裁量的合理范围。”针对“黑色星期六”森林大火举行了一场皇家调查委员会听证会，旨在审查政府森林大火战略的各个方面。它在布伦丹·索洛克受审之前就开始了，因此并未涉及他参与丘吉尔大火的情况，而是侧重于应急服务人员和受害者在火灾发生前、发生期间以及发生后的经历与反应。委员会赞扬了许多体现勇气、主动精神和专业精神的实例，这些举措提高了社区和消防员的安全，保护了房屋和财产，并支持了当地既要扑灭大火又面临自身家园和企业风险的消防队伍。
However, they determined that the incident management team for the Churchill fire demonstrated shortcomings in management and planning that contributed to the lack of organization and affected the efficiency of those working on the ground. This included the planning officers' inaccurate reporting of the time of the severe wind change, which occurred an hour earlier than predicted. The commission acknowledged the efforts of individuals such as CFA volunteer and captain of the Willung South Fire Brigade, Craig Wood. Throughout Black Saturday, Wood and his crew focused on suppression and asset protection in response to the Churchill fire, at times placing themselves at great risk. They helped divert the fire away from Tarragan South and protected the Lui Yang power station, while also safely evacuating a number of people from Kaligny. During the day, Wood's own farm came under threat and was left unprotected. In response to the choice he faced, Wood remarked, My task was far greater than my own farm.
然而，他们认定丘吉尔大火的事件管理团队在管理和规划方面表现出不足，这导致了组织工作的缺乏，并影响了地面人员的工作效率。这包括规划人员对严重风向转变时间的不准确报告，该变化比预测的时间提前了一个小时发生。委员会赞扬了诸如CFA志愿者兼威伦南南部消防大队队长克雷格·伍德等个人的努力。在整个“黑色星期六”期间，伍德和他的船员们专注于针对丘吉尔大火的灭火和资产保护，有时将自己置于极大的危险之中。他们协助将火势从塔拉根南部引开，保护了路易杨发电厂，同时安全疏散了卡利尼的许多人。白天，伍德自己的农场受到威胁，且无人保护。面对面临的选择，伍德评论道：“我的任务远比我自己的农场重要得多。”
This, he said, was something he kept in the back of his mind, so he could instead, quote, Concentrate on what you need to do for the betterment of the larger and broader community. The commission noted, Mr Wood and his crew provide just one example of the courage and generosity of men and women who fought the fires on February 7, 2009. Despite the timely warning from Victorian Premier John Brumby the day prior to Black Saturday, many Victorians were not prepared for the ferocity of the fires, and the subsequent trauma was significant. According to a report by the Herald Sun, in the five years following that catastrophic day, there was a rise in suicides, family violence reports, alcohol and drug abuse, and addictive behavior such as gambling amongst bushfire survivors. Many replacement houses were left in various stages of construction as residents had run out of money to see the job to completion and increased fireproofing had added to the cost. Every year on February 7, memorials are held throughout Victoria to commemorate the lives lost in the Black Saturday fires.
他说，这是他铭记在心的一点，这样他就可以改为“专注于为了更大、更广阔社区的福祉而需要去做的事情”。委员会指出，伍德先生和他的船员们仅仅展现了2009年2月7日扑灭大火的广大男女同胞的勇气与慷慨的一个缩影。尽管维州州长约翰·布伦比在“黑色星期六”前一天发出了及时警告，但许多维州人对火灾的凶猛程度毫无准备，随后的创伤也十分巨大。《太阳先驱报》的一篇报道显示，在那场灾难性的一天之后的五年里，幸存者中的自杀率、家庭暴力报告、酒精和药物滥用，以及诸如赌博等成瘾行为均有所上升。许多重建的房屋处于不同的建设阶段，因为居民已经耗尽了资金无法完工，而不断增加的防火措施也增加了成本。每年的2月7日，维多利亚州各地都会举行纪念活动，纪念在“黑色星期六”大火中失去生命的人。
In Churchill, locals gather to pay their respects to the families and friends of Alfred and Scott Friendo, Colin and David Gibson, Alan, Miros and Luke Jacobs, Nathan Charles, Annette Lethem, Martin Schulz and Gertrude Martin. During one such ceremony 12 months after the blaze, the chaplain of Monash University in Gippsland, Father Hugh Brown, told the crowd of mourners, It couldn't destroy our memories, it can't destroy our gratitude for the help we received from so many, and it couldn't destroy our spirits, which are strangely battered and bruised, but are never quenched. 2009 was a bloody awful year, but we, as the song says, will survive. We won't ever forget the past, but we won't live there either, because we know that out of ashes, new life grows. Music There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在丘吉尔，当地人聚集在一起，向阿尔弗雷德和斯科特·弗里恩多、科林和大卫·吉布森、艾伦、米罗斯和卢克·雅各布斯、内森·查尔斯、安妮特·莱瑟姆、马丁·舒尔茨以及格特鲁德·马丁的家属和朋友表达敬意。在火灾发生12个月后举行的这样一场仪式上，吉普斯兰莫纳什大学的牧师休·布朗神父对哀悼的人群说：“它无法摧毁我们的记忆，它无法摧毁我们对从这么多人那里得到的帮助的感激之情，它也无法摧毁我们的精神，尽管它们饱经风霜、伤痕累累，但从未被扑灭。2009年是个血腥糟糕的一年，但正如歌里所唱的那样，我们会挺过去的。我们永远不会忘记过去，但我们也不会活在过去，因为我们知道，灰烬之中，新生命正在成长。”音乐本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。